exister quoi il va gagner aujourd'hui
regarde cette coupe de cheveux c'est
plus pareil hein ça a pas de la petite
espagnole là ils retroussent les manches
il est très très chaud
tu vas faire à trois
voire moi j'espère avoir une belle
partie qu'ils gagnent ou qu'ils perdent
en fait
s'il gagne tant mieux pour lui s'il perd
tant pis mais qu'il joue quoi
bein retard carton rouge à thon rouge
victoire sur ce nom mais c'est pas
normal à 6 voilà être en retard quand
même fin je sais pas moi
c'est vraiment le match du non respect
du public en tout cas
même si c'est ça le volatile mais voyez
du retard
même chaise comme ils n'ont pas mis la
game s'en foutent fut personnes photo
diffusée le speech est tout ce qu'ils
agressent fait j'ai ils ont juste pas
mis les genkois
est là et est complètement loin quoi
c'est un événement important
site où saute on reviendra
mais c'est beau quand on fait un nda
requête dans ce sens existent
voilà parfait yoyo
ida pouces en option ah ben voilà
il est très chaude et déjà fait peu 4
i
way c'est en fait s'il fallait commencer
enfin après
c'est sûr qu'il avait commencé comme sa
première ronde c'était pas la même
ouais c'est terrible
ça se joue tellement à travailler ses
députés derrière donc plus chic ouais
ils ont peu promet moscou a merdé la pop
ce bon piont là
mais c'est un crâne à quel point ce jeu
c'est mental quand même
ça pas du tout être la même partie il ya
plus de feuilles a plus rien
vers cette coupe de cheveux lui va
beaucoup mieux ah bah oui à vrai dire
si gaillard comme ce à quoi
il va pas avoir d'autre aujourd'hui mais
tu fait très peur il
c'est marrant quand même
il fallait qu'ils fassent enfin ils sont
vraiment dos au mur qu'il fasse
complètement de la merde pour enfin
jouer aux échecs bravo n'importe quoi
voyez-vous quattro ben ali aux 4 on est
venu faire jetteront
paf y clic je vais m'en grand plomb
grand plan pour voir
bah lui a beaucoup bien ça être coupants
fait d'aller très bien la magnifique
halle
ils auraient dû faire cette coupe de
cheveux depuis très longtemps en fait
beaucoup mieux que le chignon
place bien à cîteaux enfin c'est plus
pareil quoi ouais c'est un autre etc ou
plus et conseils de karuïa keane les
vire est ce type
fuyards équine dans l'équipe joue très
bien quoi c est qu alger 3
mais pas le fond b5
fou en g2 j'écoutais que j'ai conseil de
ville at je fais comme toi en fait
une catalane tu vas te faire du bien
mais ce serait beau qui reviennent il ya
eu la partie oui
6/4 ya kids at war kids with you anymore
s'expose tout le tort
nostra va du style en fait comme un
comédien on se lève un petit peu oui
bien
changé de
nom mais il peut vraiment gagner
aujourd'hui il m'a l'air d'être beaucoup
je sais pas je le sens beaucoup plus
tranquille a déjà la coupe de cheveux ça
ne va plus avant avant le point écoute
moi c'est et coupe de cheveux le sait
quattro
prévost qui se passe des cicatrices coup
et je mets des dents ferraille comme
requinquant qui pose un hip hop il pose
le khalife sur l'achat alors la partie
quoi il vient si tu veux tu vas faire
des bouts tatouage ou ce coffre peut
voir son corps sa chemise ouverte
à tout le monde gagne par forfait fait
très attention
comment tu vas faire pour jouer sous
assistance respiratoire
mais dieu
c'est ça c'est comme freezer maintenant
ils utilisent 2 % à distance
le tatouage maori sur le visage comme
mike tyson ce serait magnifique
le premier coup la partie est jouée par
vladimir poutine
[Musique]
et vient avec un petit bouton nucléaire
attention
tu veux la partie comme tu veux mais
fais très attention aux résultats à
magnus choisi s'agit
d'un petit sous marin comme ça au dessus
de côté d'oslo qui
portera justement nucléaire ce matin qui
est passé près aux frontières comme ça
bon ben on va voir enfin là on peut rien
dire il a changé d'ouverture ça fait
plaisir enfin des échecs peut-être que
ce match nous réserve encore beaucoup de
surprises fab ah bah ça serait plaisant
finalement bah oui enfin une partie
bon après on n'a pas semblé trop vite
mais déjà ils essayent quelque chose
donc ça fait plaisir d'essayer quelque
chose
lorsque pourquoi ils mangent pas le pion
au bail pour elle mangeait silva s'est
même pas mauvais coup alors les blancs
font damas quatre énormes engins bien
sûr et donc l'idée c'est d'enlever un
pion du centre des noirs donc le pion
des pour ensuite avec les blancs pousser
et puis l'absence de ce tueur des cinqs
fait vivre le fou g2 et cetera mais il
se trouve que 5 ou job il
ya une très bonne idée serait battu avec
un petit couteau opinel et tu taille un
peu les cavaliers quoi tu zeghida les
cavaliers
et les oreilles et en guinée
ja doubles
fautes 6 heures sur l'échiquier
tu écris en bas qui au couteau tu gr20
baky devant toi
c'est génial torse walder qui divaguent
liste réfléchi à la façon de transposer
dans le 26 mars
[Rires]
d'autres l'ordre de coûts mais très bon
tard zelda là il a déjà des blagues bien
cadré
je n'arrivais pas à transposer
un peu d'ambition côté russe bah oui
déjà sa coupe dessous est ambitieuse
quoi
on est très confiant pour nous
aujourd'hui
audi quattro
il a tendu
pourquoi pas je n'ai pas très belle
réunion il pas encore ces cinq
des cuatro ok
ça prépare ah bah c'est sûr mais
je connais pas tellement c'était quattro
laurier quelques parties bien sûr bon
j'imagine qu'ici c'est marie qui est
extraordinaire c'est normal mais
est clairement des cuatro 5 ou assez
rare faire les bons joueurs blancs ce
qu'ils ont fait ding dong korobov
c'était du bas ce qui a fait qu'ils
feront norman saut en blitz il a fait
mais quoi trop mais bkc n'est pas une
grosse ligne non mais là c'est rare un
métier qu'elle sait pas on n'a pas fait
une partie une fois non mais je pense
qu'on a fait c'est pas ça enfin
j'imagine su se montrer ce que c'est la
grosse ligne ses cavalières 3 au premier
coup
des think au regard des bons fessée
quattro desing cook
voilà kf3 donc ce serait quelque 3 des 5
c 4 des 4 b 4e et 5e 6e 5 et compagnie
là c'est un peu différent quoi
avec les blancs tu viens me des pièces
tel fonds g2 qui tapait si tu veux jouer
une sorte de benoni averse était là et
donc faire le jeu des plans avait que
trois pour casser avec b4 c'est norman a
et c est à une partie d'échecs en fait
je ne peux pas dire que l'on soit mieux
votre
bic app c'est un coup spots ligne sur
les quatre segments damas car
donc appuyons imprenable donc
[Musique]
voilà ah oui c'est ça m'a tuer la montre
et une partie je me disais que j'avais 3
et 5 ouais bon kf3 c'est clairement un
coup normalement bkc
avec effroi 5 soit transposé dans des
trucs un peu plus gros est bon je ne
peux fermer quatre sites en ville peut
faire 2 3 tu peu rauque et fr3 plus tard
mais
je re 3 vite ma part je sais pas
moi je suis arrivé 4 juste pour
empêcher ces 5eme place et
m'a pris je joue très mal ses positions
un bébé 4 c'est sûr ça va au fond je
sais pas quelle meilleure ici jeudi mais
b4 c'est sûr que c'est pas con et kf3
évidemment normal mais kf3 qu'est ce que
c'est dommage quand même d'avoir vu son
d'anti marshall quand tu vois ça bon
peut-être qu'il va pas avoir mieux
moyens truqués
et dans l'attitude déjà 120 messages et
c'est un truc là oui c'est un tel regret
je pense parce que sa
filiale anti marshall magnus est
vraiment le meilleur joueur du monde il
est imprenable dessus mais là je sais
pas mais c'est sûr que tu as plus de
chances de perdre de gagner mais tu as
plus de chances de le bouger en fait
ouais même si tu ne bouges pas battu le
force à je veux par lui même et pas
faire ci connaît par coeur non mais de
marc shaiman youssef un anti marshall
c'est le meilleur joueur dans tim
marshall de l'histoire des échecs c'est
sur
ces possibles pas en fait
probablement déjà
aussi pour le simple fait que
qui ont envoyé moi avance et du coup là
il a une position qui est peut-être pas
moins bien pour les noirs mais au moins
mais en fait je sais pas depuis quand le
marshall
certainement réputé bon
parce que en
fait quand j'étais petit
bon c'était les vraies espagnol rudy
mais avec des si ce quoi lemarchal qui
on savait que ça existait un vrai bon je
bouffe le pion est un peu de jeu mais ça
va
mais déjà chez 2k sports à fond 93 il a
rien trouvé contre moi c'est moi quand
j'étais petit j'étais content je savais
pas mais je vais pas me jeter un enfant
donc donc voilà huit ans savait déjà
[Musique]
d'ailleurs après fois qu'on a joué
lemarchal je pensais que le mode à
s'arrêter conquois si je savais pas que
ça existait j'étais vraiment j'en fais
ta vie bonne option je bouffe puis je
pars la partie et je vais pas jeter
super dégoûté quoi je perds contre un
abruti qui peut remplir micoud c'est
incroyable
ok je crois qu'il sait si socke est donc
ils jouent sans ces cinq ne veux pas
avoir deux sortes de bankoa mersey
bref mais dont près de 93 question raffy
sava et lui faisait à 4 contre short
et
puis et puis j'ai longtemps considéré
avoir pas mal les années 2000 en fait
mais que c'est plutôt berne en fait que
le marshall ce aussi bien réputé
parce qu'avant toutes les parties de
[Musique]
marshall par exemple n'aurait jamais tu
sais même pas en tête une partie de
fisher contre le hall marshall par
exemple c'était un genre de spéciale
fischer
j'en ai pas en tête je sais pas
peut-être donc soit vous abandonnez mais
juste pour dire quoi tu vois
bon
remplacer les pièces dans l'ouverture
c'est déjà important fait ce qui se
passe ici à
charge parce qu'il 66 ok merci tort
zolder guitare zolder idée d'à quoi ils
cliquent un
essai donné que la victoire se passe
kiptenden j'étais dans les tribunes
j'ai vraiment très surpris
du coup à rennes là une femme enceinte
de fisher c'est sa vie à chercher cet
immense parce qu'ils sachent exposition
support par curiosité et chicken en fait
4 5
coût d'entrée on va avoir une partie
aujourd'hui ça c'est déjà la bonne
nouvelles pâtures bodereau aurait pu
aussi un ouais non mais c'est bien un
dépôt bravo en fait ils abandonnent pas
le match bon il ya très peu de chances
de revenir sera pas mais il essaye un
truc aujourd'hui s'ils gagnent
aujourd'hui relance quand même à siegen
mourir lancé un petit peu aussi mais
plusieurs fissures aux quais jusqu'au
s'est passé parti l'a donc oui qu'on se
passe qui la fmu
g3
consistant
j'avais quelques une fiche a pas des
masses mais quand même même
quelques-unes au blanc du cou blanc a
non réclamés faisait pas eu quatre ou
cinq poissons meurent
hockey
parce qu'ils quel gros joueurs quand un
bruit
du coup racf ou c5 ok bon c'est une
nouvelle fois une version hyper rare
dans la pratique j'ai que six parties
dans ce que je vois
et pas vraiment nouveaux joueurs donc
c'est une pollution frêche est ok magnus
n'arrive à faire je vais les positions
frêche en fait chaque jour quasiment des
trois logiques d'un trio jacques
caillaut 7 en fait ça son idée de
parfums qui réussissent plutôt je sais
pas
si ça me paraît bien pour les blancs
ça va en fait avec les normes et
ça joue sajou
genre compte en art ont plongé de bien
ouverts
si tu es content mais bon déjà ils sont
content aussi de parachever ses cinq en
général parce qu'ils ont la case pour
mettre une pièce où ils sont ravis
d'être un cavalier s'ils peuvent donc
bon c'est pour ça qu'il est c'est
bizarre par rapport à quercy cependant
ces cinq mais après est-ce qu'ils auront
le temps à autre chose mais souvent on
aime bien faire qualifier ce qui est des
sept qui essaient 5 tu ne sécurisent par
hassen qui après tu te donne l'option
poussé au centre
il fait autre chose c'est fou ces cinq
donc justin blindes le pion des quatre
il a envie de garder un oeil sur les 2 3
voilà après ce qui nous fait qu'il ya
cette qualif si je sais pas j'ai pas
quel plan il a en fait magnus de
placement de pièces
furent il ya eu cinq ou pas je pense que
tu aimerais bien mettre un jour
après jour peut-être qu'il imagine qu'il
a le temps après clémence à sousse doit
faire [ __ ] 4 kallio 5 tu vas pas le
tolérer si facilement
compliqué après le truc bizarre que j'ai
remarqué dans ma propre pratique
normalement en fait si j'avais les noirs
tu peux les deux camps de différentes
couleurs serait hyper heureux de la
pression blanche
serait hyper heureux parce que ni mon
adversaire fait juste rien et je veux
pour l'avantagé c'est un truc est
souvent plus les blancs ils se sentent
au lieu de faire un peu un truc parce
qu'ils ont les blancs ces gens qui donne
un devoir moral je sais pas d'où alors
quand tu joues avec les noirs tu es
contente juste égaliser il se monte à
fait avec les ventes n'avaient pas
tellement à déstabiliser l'homme des
fois je tentais djegherif 3g 3d 3 mais
bon il faut une pire qu'à l'envers quand
tu fais la pire qu'avec les noirs c'est
un côté un peu provocateur c'est pas un
client il est en vie un peu de la tête
sous ils font des trucs font pas juste 4
d-4d 3 c3 qui les deux je suis pas en
fin d'un certain qu'ils font mais non du
regret mais ça y est les couleurs
inversées ils essayent pas et ça change
en fait la dynamique donc en fait n'est
pour elle et noir avec cette opposition
blanche
bon là il a l'air très content en fait
je dirais mais
j'ai toujours senti ça qu'en fait je
voulais que les noirs pour plus ou moins
égaliser genre truc c'est pas si dur
l'impression
est tombé c'est un bon mais b4y essaye
de tout faire pour l'éviter 1,4 wire à 5
ouais je sais pas à ce que
[Musique]
ce que b 3 c'est une idée pour les
blancs
o'keeffe 6 b 3 je sais pas
normal au maroc
il en b3 il va le placer en v3
remontantes une pression sur demande et
en fait c'est kate moss est je crois et
peut-être 3 ok ok si ce qui est des deux
c'est intéressant alors expliqué
peut-être chipote quoi je
dirais même
un peu mieux mieux qu'elle et ses 6 me
placer en fait on va faire des captures
a pas de ces 5 pouces et 8 s'il est
toujours en c'est vite
dit peut-être pas si con way à 5 après
faut voir si le 5 pour les noirs bien
sûr s'ils maintiennent ça ça va mais
peut-être là les échanges c'est un petit
plus passez vous bouffe pression soigné
meubles 6,6 ok mais ont fait de ces deux
années les premiers faire des qualifs 5
détour d un des petits trucs peut-être
ces 5 eca se dessine je sais pas ça va
peut-être deux trois trucs à faire là
dessus
donc des trois quilles si ce qui est des
deux peut-être souffert à 5
comme ça au moins on anticipe qu'ils
avaient transigé fois ça se fera à 4.8
ont calé simon bête
je suis quand même peut-être tu peux
faire c'est une question
d'heures
ouais
bon c'est hyper surprenant mais en fait
c'est pas si débile
si un jour on pourra prendre ces options
à quatre c'est ça le truc de fer 7 35
revient ces cinq peut-être
rhône des 81 ans présente pas bon ça ok
on est un peu long va fermer 4 milliard
soit damas quatre tours bien soit je
sais pas quoi on pressent des quatre on
est bien
mais qu'on a une petite idée
intéressante c'est à dire qu'on devrait
cailloux 4 un moment aussi aux de faire
des km et 3 confère ce l'était échanger
et on se donne à cause des trois pour
qu'il y ait enfin quelqu'un qui a eu des
trois
est intéressant et la magnus
bon il tombe de souvenirs de trucs bah
ça sinon ça sur ouais ça sue face à
suffisait
d'arrêter la connerie
baroin c'est bien qu'il l'ait fait une
fois
on va voir
si les poken celle là c'est quand même
très cool pour le match au
volant j'imagine que c'est trop tard
quoi qu'il en soit mais bon c'est juste
pas le même homme là dans son attitude
donc c'est déjà bien fait
ray magnus le seul regret qu'on va avoir
c'est que comme il très stressé en début
de match j'y monte un peu en puissance
petit à petit ça on l'a dit là il ya à
son avantage de 2-0 il quand même plus
relax que si tu ne mets cette position à
0 0 et que
c'est qu'il doit pas perdre ça sent la
merde quoi là bon tu t'as pas envie de
perdre sa présence et son adversaire
mais si ça arrive
ça va c'est pas la fin du monde
parce que après tu mets toute mon équipe
sur sur les c4 g3
tu trouves un truc safe et essaye de
faire mais enfin c'est pas la famille
ont convaincu de perdre cette partie
quoi il préférerait parfois ça c'est
évident
mais comme tu le dis même position à la
partie 6 avec les blancs à 0 0 la partie
de la première ronde
vous êtes la première ronde en fait
bon papa tournage c'était dommage d
assaut stratégie quoi qu'il en soit mais
si jamais le premier jour vous après
avoir été champion du monde tu as besoin
de pas trop de risques juste de toucher
les pièces et de mettre dans l'ambiance
et surtout anti marshall et de faire une
nulle
je sais pas répond en fait
mais après très vite fallait pas insisté
catherine rey
il a enfin
une position qui joue avec les blancs
jean lui dire
bon en fait il suivez son c4
mais il n'a pas fait donc
jusqu'à saint parce que c'est mauvais de
fer à 4 dans l'espagnol sait très bien
c'est un bon coup mais c'est que comme
magnus c'est pas assez bien il vaut
mieux cuisse et position donc voilà et
là au moins bon c'est autre chose dit
tenter un truc et c'est bien
qu'ils essayent de se rappeler d'un truc
ouais
ah mais il n'a pas joué au hasard stand
de couffins
dire c'est suffisamment rare de jouer
des 4 et compagnie
enfin c'est pas une improvisation dans
l'échiquier donc je sais pas trop quel
schéma de mettre en place justement ce
que je te dis peut-être caillou sept
sont des fiefs cif
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas son
placement pièce avec les noirs en fait
j'ai juste quasiment jamais vu ça et
bien sûr parce qu'il y avait six parties
dans la base et aucune de l'élite
donc
on sait rien en fait un
complexe
que damas quatre est un coup bas le truc
c'est que ces eaux noires de jouer
donc non
et sinon
un peu bizarre mais pourquoi pas un gîte
voulait faire des pressions sur ses six
et que les cloisons mais
ça se trouve je sais pas où se trouve
serait pas trop bien je devrais 4
bronze
art de ces fous 17 mai
la taille de l'échiquier crois que ces
détails 6
ha ok je suis pas sûr bon c'est un gros
chic à quoi
t'attendre manu s'était pas prêts de
joueurs
pros
comme une diagonale ou à des fuites à 3
et les dessus quoi
ok donc kayak fils alors en déshérence
dans laquelle des deux nous
attendent à nouveau quelques partis
là-dessus finalement cette position les
uns des trucs qu'on a rapporté oui
[Musique]
à shenzhen cette année un rapide et jeu
calée à 3 rapporte bon pour revenir en
c2 essayer d b quattro une autre partie
de cabu gyan contre bilel
la coupe du monde
en juillet et jeudi et deux à cinq qui
avait trois trucs qu'on a regardé double
gamme fusion
mais de weggis en
2009 y avait eu 4 et si bizarre j'aime
pas trop
bon ce temps rapide mais après
donc sur vire à gonzalez quevedo
reynaldo cinq cubains il effectuera les
a3 et après ça buzze raymond
et l'ordi alors dit
je leur dis je vais me lancer je peux
mettre un petit
outil stockfisch valley
stockfisch dans les gammes
bon les ordis profondeur 54 coups à fond
qui a et b d2 même mon petit stockfisch
brydon 0,30 c'est pas grand chose mais
c'est pas
000 t contente que c'est beaucoup
mais bon après peut-être en poussant
certains vers 00 oui oui bon bah t'as
son genre car ça n'a rien fait de mal il
a développé les pièces il avait des
pions au centre et le dé 4,5 ou
questionnable m dans cette structure
généralement on dit qu'on aime bien
garder les pions au centre sur blanc
pour bloquer le fou j'ai deux donc ok de
tempo tempo iasi de retour
bien
alors c'est 5 juste mettre un petit coup
les lilas va et on a vu votre chaise
vide la chaise vide à ce bon agent
spécial ali dont il te fait qu'il y ait
des deux donne 53%
la mieux que 5050 abbaoui
et
étonnamment un des meilleurs coûts
d'après ya ces drames et le fond un set
ça même ses meilleurs coups mais ne
monte pas content
ouais mais c'est meilleur que
moi
c'est logique mais demande qu'on a vu
avec le cahier b3 food et de machins
ça laisse pas le a5 qui fait une grande
impression en tête qui est b3 du coup tu
vas pas à cette tu vends aux sept états
tiennent qui aimait trop à faire le
guignol là-bas pour rien que ça peut
être solide on va voir s'il a la cia de
20 h à
6 h
30 également un peu content avec les
blancs quoi
on verra on verra mais logique et bd
dans tout cas
ils croient pas abbas du coin c'est le
gabut gyan
karl states un mec j'ai déjà croisé dans
des open je pense qu'un jour allemand
qui casse tête
cartographes et hockey dont il ya que
trois jeux trois mecs
en magnus on va voir si ce rappel ou pas
1h40 bah ça ne fait plus réfléchir que
quand il affronte retour du touage 6
dans l'anti marshall en tout cas surtout
qu'est deux voies
légales raconte quoi dans ce cas là bas
n'est pas changé d'ouverture c'est
intéressant et du cou
ou sept partis qui joue c'est que le
début mais intéressant
d'entendre une musique
mais non
ce n'est que le début d'accord d'accord
un terrible
bon c'est le moment de vérité pour
magnus ses plus
hauts à 10 ans il n'a pas fait le schéma
le plus simple quand tu
[Musique]
pourrais citer
après il a fait un schéma très
surprenant peut-être justement pour
pouvoir pour surprendre mais il ne donne
pas l'impression d'avoir surpris en fait
voilà on est posée c'est de faire du
tempo machine de cliquer au prince tant
il fait que des coups dans mon nez
pointu c'est bien et c'est lors de la
première pub aux femmes a déjà on à
paris mais on n'a pas vu passer son
frère devient alors celui en demi heure
de jeu sa part en pub instantanément las
cobas
banos
bim c'est parti
c'est parti
bon
car ça réfléchit un côté magnus
et s'est fait pas semblant
l'attitude
regarde la lune et machin cela il a
fonds
à viser la lune ça lui fait peur hein
les plus petits par les gens sont
mécontents mais il faut un
procès on veut faire la fameuse oppose
si vous préférez
apprend comme un ballon et pose pourra
refaire le match à le machin on aura des
pauses sur les autres chaînes en fait
j'ai regardé font des pauses de 10
minutes toutes les heures
plus des petites ce me pose est est fait
les tarifs à fond et ont vraiment
beaucoup de plus de pauses en fait
que deezer chat
heureux de voir des pubs peut-être ben
je croirais il ya plus cette culture de
la pub là pouvoir
a toutes tailles si
vous pensez que m'a glissé hors
caillibot probablement pas mais
peut-être isner il ne se rappelle pas
non mais vu je sais pas trop ce qui est
du fer se font ces 50
et à
peut-être je le découvrirai va nous
faire un bon truc y va il va à nier la
du velléités de dépôt
actuel je me dis qu'il ya moyen de faire
un petit truc et que les blancs dont
l'aura rimac toile qu'est alors soit
c'est
al à dos et de
sister
welsh et bats la noche c'est la noche
média jeu suivant del diablo
des liens entre
la sortie d'el dia comme ça nulle part
quoi bon c'est sûr c'est pas le mauvais
nous on se comprend tahar ben ouais mais
c'est pas si tard moi je trouve quand
même une part d c'était après midi
la bourse de la tarde évoqué baudelle
jazz bien je pense ça dans mon esprit et
bien qu'elle est jolie en choisissant la
catalane plutôt que l'espagnol les
pauvres quand ils sont l'indépendance
par rapport à cette seconde en jolie
leur esprit
mot d'esprit plus de jeux d'esprit jeu
de mots d'esprit
non la petite cuba qui fait du bien et
lyon font enfin une partie maintenant
que tu as on ya beaucoup moins de monde
qui suit on va peut-être enfin avoir une
partie un autre tout le monde a fui
le plus personne ne me regardez ce
tournoi on va peut-être enfin avoir des
vrais des belles parties d'échecs pour
récompenser
les plus courageux
pas réfléchi en tout cas côté magnus a
su
dans le retour du beau jeu actualise la
page histoire d'avoir encore une pub
c'est beau ça ah bah oui merci
à temps il a joué
sinko hockey j'attendais un assez
bon et b3 ses attendus
j'ai passé attendu 6 me regarda fawcett
le coup mais je suis même pas sûr enfin
fawcett pourquoi pas on va faire 3 quand
même
mais peut-être que tu ajoutes unis en
force qui va pas les noirs et que la
prétendue magnus et que bastien quoi
[ __ ] tellement bizarre 7,6 et ça
ça me ferait chier que ce soit ça
c'est que de la merde d'ordi aucun coup
logique un fonds c5 qui repend le set tu
te rends toi tu écrives 6 kg 4 et si ça
se trouve c'est très fort et ça fait 0 0
mais
ça me ferait chier que ça
je sais que ça me ferait chier pas que
toi mais les échecs c'est un peu devenu
sa
réussite et de ses très bons coups mais
ça fait aucun sens
ferait pas plaisir je pense qu'il va
avoir non mais peut-être 20 je suis même
pas sûr mais je
devrai sexy fait c'est que c'est sûr que
ça ordi c'est pas lui qui va jouer sa
soirée chier c'est pas normal c'est
court
[Musique]
mais c'est sûr que c'est pas c'est pour
ça qu'on dit on par exemple en rapide ça
c'est des prépas qu'on ne pourrait pas
avoir trop est logique bah voilà ici
c'est vraiment parker et mais c'est
surtout ça enfin qu'un
truc c'est que tu as le temps de te
remémorés oui je suis inquiet j'ai
quatre ont déjà fait mieux cette tempête
à mon fils bush deux fois et que tu
arrives à restituer
mais si ce récent 6 6 a pas tellement
tu te fais trop de problèmes en fait eu
enfin la grande et belle quoique leur
semble
donc ne faut surtout pas ouvrir ce sujet
deux c1 peut nourrir le tam chaîne abc
jette nourrir un petit un beauf
récupère des des items chez l'adversaire
il renforce mais enfin je sais pas trop
quand ils marchent en fait
c'est pas en club le donne à bouffer en
décomptant
ça oui c'est
terrible
bon une dernière ronde ya cru quoi c'est
pourquoi
[Rires]
aujourd'hui rien à reprocher à neo cons
après c'est bien joué mais oui c'est
jamais agréable de regarder d
sinon regarderai le tc chez patois
3 fera tellement logique vous rendez
vous si on fait ce qui embête roi il
faut aucun sens sinon on était là pour
faire pression sur des 4 et 6 s'il se
prend 1,4 il rentre juste la queue entre
les jambes en d2 donc si tu veux faire à
quatre avec l'élan était de le prendre
je te fait des trous partout
bon après ça se trouve c'est juste match
à quatre essais de 3 le coût des
logiques ça c'est sa conception point là
peut-être plus on prend
bon après tout je sais pas bon oui enfin
bon c'est terrible c'est que c'est sûr
qu'il a fait il a joué puisque trois
j'imagine armées
sainte croix koné pour il laisse
ainsi bosse à montrem la prépa parce que
j'ai en moi je n'ai même pas regardé des
coupures ayant fait
un buzz
savaient qu'on a quand même l'impression
gens qui m'ont de regarder beaucoup de
coups d'ordi
on leur dit qu'ils prendraient 4 tu peux
pas parce que le pont était à eux deux
le coup d'avant tu défends parce qu'avec
deux cas mais qui y attaquent des cas
traités dans deux pièces aussi qui sait
si c'est donc la structure n'est pas
prenable du coup avec le travail on
menace de le prendre c'est pour ça qu'on
imagine des preuves hyper logique
peut-être qu'il ya eu 5 aussi comme
beaucoup des noirs mais bon les blancs
vont prendre et
c'est autre chose et ça a priori c'est
la ligne ordinateur est ce qu
il a way ccc avec samus un bon choix
pour voir ce qui se passe
il est où ce con
non mais c'est pas le jeu qui est devenu
les gens dans le chat se
0,16
jiafu 3 mai 19 aux trois petits rock
et oui ils ont de toute façon c'est pas
le jeu c'est la 4 médias c'est sûr en
fait 5 ça fait pas trop sens je pense
être
écoutés on va voir
ce qu'on va voir les champions du monde
- fort aux échecs mais justin quayle
mémoire non non ça c'est pas possible
parce qu'en fait c'était moins fort des
chèques juste je te faire à 3 au premier
coup et quant aux dribbles et roche ont
fait déjouer trois donc non n'en faut
avoir les deux
elle est chef qui reste désespérément
vide
j'en ai eu un petit sursaut et puis a
géré sans que ça repart comme les autres
jours
mais ok - gamme de
voiliers eu ces quartiers-là de cheveux
et rassure socoa des comptes encore il a
tenté un truc mais bon ça se trouve
c'est pas 0-0 c'est juste une passion à
y aller que ça va jouer et jamais que le
marché entre marchal
sont particulièrement
bon je pense il a bouffé e5 ça fait bon
ça des champions mais c'est fragile en
fait un peu avec les normands
savoure trop la tour 1 le fouet 4les
qu'ils aillent aux cinq qui vont partir
et c'est donc wade salaire
normal
vous souvenez pas
je peux peut-être retrouver le fichier
du coup je leur dis dans les yeux
voire de conclusion si on mettait c'est
en avance
sur la base du
hockey
à ce malaise j'aimais bien je savais que
les blancs
même sympa savaient clairement aussi
bien en fait mais un moment c'est devenu
plus populaire
j'ai moins aimé césaire ça commence à
bien savoir quand j'ai mes choix je vais
plutôt un bon soir en jeu ça
ça peut être
des bases ouais après le problème c'est
que il ya tellement avoir deux couches
est pas
normal 3 tempo attendu
j'imagine même en raccourcissant les
carences y trouverez des lignes d'ordi
nom serait pas possible en fait
c'est plus dur juste parce que la magzi
cela quelle machine longtemps pour se
souvenir 25 minutes et bombe à cilacap
suite à la pendule faisait mine qui
aurait perdu autant
donc juste pour dire ça après bon
bon caisse paul beorn de cours déjà
holy temps battre le truc sur la partie
5 que magnus gagne ça je vous quand même
sur des gaffes ça joue pas sur magnus
qui a écrasé les peaux non pas du tout
et oui ça joue sur magnus une position
égal pendant 5 ou non mais la masse de
gaffes fait de vraiment la grosse quand
même dépossédé 24 je comprends toujours
pas d'avoir des rapports avant
s'expliquer il veut jouer lien je sais
pas ce qui fait il calcule mal ils
veulent ils évaluent mal fait un truc
mal en fait
peu importe mais quand il fait d'aveux
4c qui jouent ils jouent plus lien quand
tu fait d'invoquer à 30 au coeur et
il sait que s'il fait froid g63 7 il le
dit en conférence oui bon ça ça fait nul
facile c'est en fait le truc du plan
dramane qui en c2 ça il a compris bien
sûr mais déjà c'était possible le coup
d'avant quand elles seront au coude
avant il est il doit avoir vu le bon
sens mais avaient fui dans l'analyse et
donc d'avocate c'est très dur expliqué
pour moi je sais pas au prix 900
annoncées partir il était bizarre bon
peu importe on va pas revenir dessus des
1000 fois ces cinq
cavaliers à croire et b3 comme petites
lignes de détendre pas qu'ils avaient
des deux n'avait pas eu tout va bien ils
seront de toi mais b3 les trois jetons
pas bon je voulais faire ça mais
ça pour ça je pourrais être des
trotteurs enfin plan comme ça on l'a pas
vue d'un très grand
voile bon sens un peu contre sa joue
quoi ok
mais ouais ok je laisse dans les
fichiers sous ses 5
9 juillet 2014 le fichier
alors on s'attend et 4 c'est sam on
n'est pas sûr d'ailleurs si c'est je
crois pas que soldier commandes
et g4 j'aurais pas le voir en fait
bon vivre mais partira devant un coût
normal quoi
ça joue ce jour dont rêve le couple
préfère cesser
mais bon on va avoir une partie comme
aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est réellement la reine
ont plus de chance que dans l'anti
marchard
savez la ligne bon les captures bon ça
c'est ce que je viens d'avoir
un autre truc à 4 qui est médicale
ouais bah écoute on va voir un feu c'est
intéressant musée ses positions en fait
il ya de la vie
kg cas je trouve vraiment ça bizarre de
la tête du cou est bizarre juste rock
scène c'est normal vers les dents sur
lequel il est gâté pas fait c'est
probablement le meilleur couleur foncée
500 kg 4
[Musique]
6 4 bah écoute et on aura la réponse est
juste trop bizarre comme coup son
ordinateur est ce que et voilà et si ça
marche ça marche je crois qu'il ya pas
d'autres commentaires à dire pour la
logique du coup quoi
parce que je veux d'abord on fout c'est
5 ça paraît logique hein juste après tu
te faire bouffer la peur de fou
j'imagine que rock je sais pas mais en
fait
a priori tu es content et que l'on ne
devrait arriver à faire des cats staff
pas vraiment d'une prostatite cette
caisse des buts pour la tour
j'ai montré un
pas complètement
c'est
ce qu'est en c5 il est celle qui dit
aimer ça passe ric rac
sketch menace rien au directoire
a tu as qui prend qu'il prend et d'un
français ça
où tu poses pas juste se décrit la dame
après était bien placé
un roman sur meu pas juste reculé une
fois que ce sera ensuite le cas l'allier
j'espère que si on recule le four
on se prennent à 4 et le cavaliere par
la queue entre les jambes mais où déjà
on attend ça je la fais pousser 5 tempo
bon décodeur hi connaissent
bon on attend face et 5 c'était vraiment
logique quoi je
l'aï connu n'est pas
parce que justement le mettre ailleurs
voilà
à 5 qui a quatre qui peut partir elle
qui avait trois ils doivent bouger ses
poils en c1 c'est moche alors en d2 bas
il fait on se bouffe et détroit aura des
pièces trop passive pas reculer tout le
monde tout le temps quoi
pousser 5 c'est la logique qui est
même agir stratégiquement c'est bien
d'échangé de gaz nord pour faire des
quatre un jour et façon si les deux mois
c'est enfin ces théories que vlad manie
si les deux on sait que c'est égal à la
fin c'est que les vannes final c'est 000
pneus en fait c'est obligatoire c'est un
truc très simple pour connaître les
valent une position voyait une prépa
c'est que normalement et dans 95% du
temps
si les deux on est ce rappel c'est que
la résolution c'est 0-0
du coup tu débit pas de la manne line et
à moins qu'ils aient un piège à la fin
ça veut pas dire qu'il aura pas une
décision difficile pour manier ce à un
moment donné mais ça veut dire que sur
jeu parfait c'est nul
c'est un bon point de repère en vrai
quand tu regardes et tu sais pas trop
ouais
même si on regarde son ordi tu sais que
c'est 0 0 ça
mais robin font preuve
après il arrive rarement que ce soit pas
le cas mais il arrive aussi que du coup
si le joueur avec les blancs connaît
vraiment bien qu'ils aient une idée
quelque part qui soit difficile à
résoudre
ça c'est tout le travail d'un backing
par exemple
de
la daf en difficulté ou quoi bah oui oui
ouais mais c'est de devoir ou est ce qui
a pu préparer quoi faire qui pourrait ne
pas connaître et que ce soit du rhin
résoud en pratique
c'est le travail d'un maquis cette année
oui
l année dernière aussi
la com des fois j'avais une cadre de
leur dis ça peut on et focus sur la
ligne 1 507 le meilleur coup que l'autre
doit connaître et des fois tu dire ok
mais il faut savoir quand on peut le
faire on fait ça aussi c'est le truc
savoir aussi jugé quand c'est simple
même en pratique jamais vu ou pas ou est
ce que ses pieds jarre presque le coût
humain ça peut être de la merde j'arrive
parti comme ça qu'on avait vu bien en
termes de prêts pas qu'on a fait sur la
chaîne durant l'année c'était la
dernière ronde devant de forest avec
kenza ont dénoncé sa part un croyant la
fn avait jusqu'au 20e coup quoi en plus
on doit faire la partie de prêtres que
oui zidane parti
prête que oui peut-être que non
un jour ça pour un tuto pour
l'installation de stock fiche mais en
fait je suis pas trop informaticien
et je pense c'est pas trop d un
stockfisch en fait justement il est
gratuit dans libre circulation tu vas
sur google tu as le trouver enfin son
moteur de recherche fructueuse
après je sais pas si ce geste base et ça
se trouve ce fut utilisée même somptueux
je sais pas
[Musique]
un
match et se base en fait c'est la base
ouais bah moi je depuis très longtemps
après il ya plein de joueurs vraiment
amateur sympa enfin c'est juste bien toi
sont deux choses parce qu'elle seule est
de nouveau sur ce que dans un moment il
était pas cherche sur steam je vais
aller jeter un oeil
un moment il avait une version le 13 su
que j'utilise mon honneur il était à 15
euros tu vois à 15 euros franchement ça
vaut le coup mais j'avais recommandé à
pas mal de monde mais je sais pas si les
gens l'ont acheté en fait
tu veux travailler ou faire une petite
jaillet 13 ouvertures c'est bien il ya
le 16 mai bon plus cher bien sûr et les
plus récents de 15 ans va faire prendre
le 16 je bosse 13 pro
j'sais pas comment l'acheter le premier
baptisé un angle envie qu'on généralise
et langues disponibles ok
mais comment tu fais
parce qu'ils comprennent rien
j'ai pas comment l'acheter
je sais pas comment faire
pour mettre le lien c'est les gens qui
réussissent en gros nous on utilise ça
comme programme enfin le 16 mai vous
pouvez peut-être avant le 13 pas cher
si en a qui savent n'hésitez pas à nous
mettre le prix que vous avez en tout cas
c'est un très bon programme pour
analyser
en fait la tasse et que vous avez accès
à une base de données donc vous avez
toutes les parties de l'histoire elles
sont la plupart du temps les plus
importants soient analysés vous pouvez
faire des stades peut chercher voilà
trier paraît lourd car des chargeurs
comment il joue et c'est ça c'est cool
vous pouvez enregistrer ce que vous
faites le revoir à l'extérieur donc
c'est bien et ce
sont les chasses base 16 hilla à 100
euros voilà après évidemment c'est un
petit peu un coup quoi
mais voilà pour travailler d'ouverture
ou quoi c'est indispensable mais pas
trop le choix
chaises comme les très grands c'est pas
mal c'est
fait c'est très bien pour commencer et
mettre un premier pied literie on va
dire et voilà elle voudra peut-être
jamais besoin de chercher ce vaste ne
l'est pas les joutes tournois une couche
pour le plaisir
[Musique]
mais ça va très bien aussi c'est juste
pour ceux qui veulent vraiment plus rail
hard
mais en fait un tabac ce sens n'a pas
besoin tu peux soit télécharger les
tweets sont gratuits ce week-end chess
soient utilisés de toute façon la base
des normes club de jazz bass qui est
compris dans le chas base avec des
suffisante pour mettre la mégane à tabac
ça ne sert absolument à rien fait moi
j'utilise absolument jamais bon tu peux
l'avoir
au juste si tu veux travailler sans
internet quoi serait-ce pour avoir 2000
et l'eau ça suffit ah bah moi je
l'utilisé encore là des utilisateurs
voir chase bazin pas
déplu au format mère ça pas besoin
d'avoir le dernier truc il ya peut-être
deux ou trois fonctionnalités en plus
mais le but en fait c'est que tu es
accès aux parties et que nous mettons
programme d'analysé avoir des bases et
que puisse les lire en fête
des petits pour avoir les deux mais
c'est bien suffisant
à mekla automatiquement non closes en
fait tu fais entrer est allé parti
c'est instantané
connexion internet je veux juste vous
êtes la dse stream que vous avez
internet
mais bon ça c'est le point que tout le
monde utilise après il ya d'autres
joueurs les ruchers se sustente ça mais
maintenant ils se mettent camacho
quand j'étais petit j'étais assistante
aussi
mais bon le truc c'est comme tout est au
format atx essbase et que c'est plus
pratique juste ultime m et puis j'avais
pas d'en savoir plus consistante que
chess bas c'était juste le vendeur d'une
boutique
d'apple trop existé mais que calyon a
vécu d'assistant de ses biens et cetera
je préfère je redis je compte
qu'assistante alors ce qui devait s p c
est déjà utilisé en open source on sait
gratuit moi je suis je pourrai jamais
utilisé est impossible en fait prenons
ce qui donne un vin elle utilise ça
parce que c'est gratuit mais enfin moi
perso je n'arriverai pas à travailler
avec j'ai essayé par curiosité c'est un
pour moi c'est très complexe après c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai pas l'habitude
mais j'ai l'impression que je tiens trop
qui travaillent avec
moi mais quand tu es pro bon tu te fais
un petit investissement c'est comme si
tu joue au tennis tu vas voir dans la
raquette
non ici de chasse comme du coup ça
suffisait pour arriver jusqu'à 1500 mhz
en fait c'est complètement différent
fait surtout chasse comme pas toutes les
leçons tu as vraiment énormément de
leçon on a des milliers déjà 130 sont
faites avec d'exercice mais au-delà de
ça tu as des vidéos le son temps là des
milliers talent et l'entraîneur tactique
le puzzle rush
les analyses de thé partitas de nouveaux
nouvelles choses pour se créer des bases
de données d'ailleurs à l'intérieur qui
commence à être créée ou tu peux traiter
propre petite base de données avec tes
petits courts mais en fait ça c'est bien
mais si tu veux passer au niveau au
dessus en fait à un moment donné faire
du tournoi à faire rimer du plus haut
niveau ben tu as besoin de
deux chaises base pour te faire des
bases de données et pour travailler des
ouvertures plus individuellement mais ça
dépend ce que vous faites voilà
tu peux arriver jusqu'à deux mille lots
en ayant que chaz comme largement et de
toutes façons de chasse base ça te fais
ça tu sers à travailler tes ouverture en
fait est de faire des bâtonnets
d'ouverture si tu compte pas le faire ça
sert absolument à rien en fait y'a aucun
outil à rien c'est juste et c'est juste
une base de données oui c'est juste même
pas une base ainsi un outil pour se
créer des bases de données
la pratique
epa ouverture par codelco parce que tu
veux
autant de basses que tu veux tu te faire
des trucs par thème tu m'as des parties
référence les analyses
restent bien
une sorte de cahier numérique ouais
c'est ça dont qui l'a fait petit ragon
ça peut peut-être un peu joué pour yann
confirmé l'option étude sur lynch est
assez intéressant pour les ouvertures
moi je trouve pas les bons après je n'ai
aucun produit utilise la norme et
stations
ckoi et fonctionnel et plus utiles
chaise basse se faire une base perso
have eyes pour ce faire des bases
données personnelles
tu peux le faire sur une chaise comment
es tu as aussi le même truc que le truc
étude qui est sur place comme aussi mais
en gros c'est moins bien en gros c'est
moins bien c'est souvent fait mais ça
peut être largement suffisant jusqu'à un
certain niveau mais selon des objectifs
est ce qu'on veut c'est juste un fait
exprès paquet il a tiré un vrai cahier
où est ce que tout se passe sur orbite
celle d'alain ce que des bases de mecha
se base en fait l'histoire du cahier si
tu connais pas l'histoire ça vient de
vlad fait qui notait tout sur ses
cahiers quand il était jeune
prix informatiques ou des balbutiements
de l'informatique on va dire
et donc il notait plein de trucs sur ses
cahiers soit des variantes des concepts
des trucs qui comprenait et voilà donc
une fois et visionner avec son cayenne
voilà l ai dit que j'avais noté dans le
cahier du cou à ces prépas cahier machin
c'est pas juste une appellation qu'on a
nous quoi qui demandent si chez
sabcestbien l'appareil je connais aucun
pro qui se prépare avec chez sable
en fait non tous les pros utilise chez
ce badge presse assistante ou équivalent
on y arrivera il n'y a pas d'alternative
en fait mais moi quand j'avais 17 18 ans
que je joue encore que je me préparais
j'avais déjà de chasse base aubin et
tout mais ouverture et tous étaient dans
chuck bass toutes les nouveautés que
j'ai pu trouver où jouer c'était tout
quelque part fatiha
adpi g13 en fait
j'avais un vieil ordi mais j'étais
assistante dessus et en fait j'avais
passé faire je sais pas j'ai mal joué
cette année là je pense que j'ai foutu
et j'avais passé un été entier à faire
refermer répertoire d'ouvertures
jusqu'au bout j'avais pas d'ordi
portable j'avais fait les cahiers bon
c'est un classeur en fait j'ai tout noté
sur des fiches cartonnées je faisais des
notaires d'ajouter tout près je parte en
tournée avec [ __ ] de classeur mais est
ce juste
je suis passé de 1200 fidh tempo en fait
mais directement de voir j'ai jeté jarre
19 70 mon fils je suis allé jouer les
tournois après qu'un répertoire et
et
22 15
en janvier 2018 et peut on dirait qu'il
sort de m 98 voilà c'est plus que du pmu
va bien je suis facile pas bien ou pas
il est comment dalhousie charges assez
onéreux c'est terrible
ah non il n'a pas l'air aussi bien aussi
fringant qu'au début nord ouest est
beaucoup plus fringants le début de la
partie ça doit gérer plusieurs fuites
d'eau par la chemise plaisir j'avais
oublié à quel point ce terreau louche
y est je suis le cas dubaï encore une
semaine
je me rappelle plus de ma prépa
sus bizarre parce que
j'ai tout boeing a repoussé cinq mais ce
doute kamke rock il ya des choses comme
ça arrivent et ils trouvent ça arrive et
on prépare et est-ce justifié
est ce que c'est ça ma vie
et vous quoi il part vivre en ardèche vd
en ardèche
jolie l'ardèche
un beau département
ouais mais en fait le truc c'est qu'en
plus ils se rappellent pas ou quoi c'est
sûr qu'il fait égaliser en force quoi
c'est un beau 0-0 est
obligé ça je sais ces prépas donc c'est
obligé c'est forcément 00
encore inattendue qui va se passer si
c'était une de ces sais quoi
d 4d blanc on ça disons 100 avec les
ordis j'avais envie de faire à 4 bon bah
ouais faut cette dame a sautillé ces
5èmes on avait eu cinq tour à tour des
huit
pieds il prend 1 4 tab à 4
n'attendons pas trop quoi keith et troy
f5 donc en fait sa crise d'options qui a
aidé cing dit et bien que les banques
prêtent à leur superbe saison mais là je
vois le mec me joue ça lui complètement
congés la case f4 pour le cheval
je gagnais un pion le quart f3 défoncer
en fait il ne s'est vraiment pas josé
chaque quine de
partager ça
voilà oui oui mais je serai à ce genre
de scénario ouais non
nulle en fait en fait l'idée des noirs
c'est que je suis déjà ce qui est des
cinq jours 30 ap de 4
heures je pensais plus d'hommes des six
pourraient fixer
le fou g2 du jeu tu attaques
mais oui avec un ordi tu comprends et
deuxième truc c'est que moi comme
mathieu disette et pour mieux marquer
pour un cadre du coup et être marrante
et b4
donc c'est quoi fausse adams est des cas
où des quatre vingt quatre bouts fouet
cas et c'est 5e 5 pour d'être tourné en
dv iii b 4
saint pacôme coup mardi 1 est présent le
sens obligé mais tu es là pour ça en
même temps qu'elle prend et je sais pas
trop et pourquoi pas seulement tu défend
mieux des quatre noms mais visuellement
j'aime bien les blancs ces jus tom bad
malheur c'est que en fait savoir
ordinateur à ce moment mais bon
j'aime bien la tête de la pression des
violences tu es mieux développer ta le
santon vasella d'afat à plein de trucs
qui parlent en sa faveur mais c'est lors
de la plupart oui ok ok a tout de suite
est ce que tu penses content d'aller
faire un match où sur vas-y moi je reste
je reste ou
pas frustrer les gens assis des frustrés
j'en ai dit allez on va on va tous au
match un match a time mais comme tu veux
enfin tu veux partir sur le match aussi
j'espère que vous allez bien
petite pause ça va pas jouer non alors
il s'est rien passé femmes on n'a rien
raté au beau jeu est un peu inquiète
[Musique]
milla n'a cessé yann point exercer cette
fonctionnaire est alors 404 belle
prépare en magnus pour le moment les
joueurs n'ont pas encore joué un coup
par eux mêmes dans cette partie
mais mais là ça va peut-être être le
premier coup de la partie en réalité
en fait c'est possible que nespouls
réfléchissent et qu'ils les skis c'est
ce qui doit jouer il sait que c'est nul
et que la bomba il cherche vas-y est-ce
que j'ai une chance pratique de jouer un
truc il n'a pas regardé etc
après c'est sûr si je vous la ligne
qu'on regarde juste avant la pause abbas
deux des quatre à quatre ou sept dames 7
6 et 5 tours des huit tout ça et ce
avant la pause 5 tour à tour des huit
que ce soit b4 où que ce soit là on
truque 1.4 ess crise d'options des noirs
malheureusement c'est 0-0 d'après leur
dis donc
il en est bien au courant donc bon bain
possible qu'il fasse une prise de risque
maintenant il joue un coup qu'il saura
être vraiment objectivement mais
je pense qu'ils cherchent sans chair
c'est pas un problème de mémoire en fait
de sa part c'est juste que il va jouer
un cours prépa
jarry le russe d'opposition et manu sont
réfléchies une heure et demie pendant
arriver là il aurait continue de réciter
ses enfants il va quand même pas tous
trouvé jusqu'au bout par lui-même il va
probablement raison le problème c'est
que juste en fait tu te prends la prépa
de stockfisch ou deux villas ou tchéquie
donc
le moment tu dois
peut-être que le score soit 0,06 frein
pour tester ça en fait tu chantes c'est
arrivé comptait absolument obligé de
gagner pour
espérer le micro chance en entrant dans
ce match
c'est possible qu'il faut autre chose
voilà je pense c'est l'explication de
cette longue réflexion maintenant
en tout cas c'est l'impression que s'il
avait commencé par ces quatre et qui
avaient envoyé des c4 elle aurait
peut-être pu eu plus de chance de
trouver des bas des petites déviations
avant un autre
et s'il n'avait pas eu quand je disais
tu aurais pedro j'avais quoi je trouve
c'est plus fort que moi parce que j'ai
pu
parce que perdre faria juste pas de
compte si on applique envers john
carlson est en plein doute y perdons
encore ron carlson
complexe comme aux deux fils ou lilas et
là ils utilisent un peu tout en fait
généralement
selon l'opposition puis c'est pas mal de
faire jouer l'un contre le web tu vois
des faits sont pas d'accord on ne sait
pas trop qui as raison tu les fais jouer
tu vois ce que ça donne
il y en a qui sont meilleurs en calcul
l'autre en stratégie bon ils sont tous
pas mal en tout je veux dire mais voilà
la position qu'il faut optimiser un
étudiant le bon logiciel dans la bonne
position
c'est qui perd mangerait ce que tu fais
c'est le thé bouillant sur l'ordinateur
les cieux casser ton ordi a pas mieux
je peux te faire une place je sais pas
si à tout qui marche
la set up la petitesse et athas
bouillante sur l'ordi portable je suis
pas sûr fab jeune des
fils à faire chauffer leur dit quoi
le cheminement pour être champion du
monde n'est pas trop dur et long aussi
candidat puis 1500 partie de 30 heures
chacune contre le champion en titre
selon françois assez sûr que le champion
du monde il est très favorisés chacun ça
c'est évident mais de tout temps faute
sur la tradition
et effectivement c'est plus simple
d'être magnus ça en fait déjà
les efforts c'est pour se qualifier aux
candidats ils perdurent et il court
après pendant deux ans quasiment état
que huit élus enfin même cette fois ci
au perdant qui te gêne classe
ouais bon travail et c'est à n'y a pas
de vote car les balais à oui oui mais
enfin mais en quelque sorte à la course
accueille chaque ami noël quart d'heure
donc si c'est très dur donc déjà tu
souffles de en fait tu en sois bon juge
les candidats ça t'apporte est juste
content d'y être mais le but final c'est
de gagner ce tournoi on tue le compte
les huit meilleurs joueurs de la planète
à part le champion du monde
hyper dur de gagner tu donnes tout tu
donnes tout jeune tout et après en plus
t'as lâché de toutes tes prépare faite
aux candidats pour tous pour les gagner
à tout lâcher et donc du coup tu te
retrouve à poil on sait ce que tu le
champion lui c'est ce que tu as fait lui
a rien montré et taxis moi pour te
remettre sur pieds pas lâcher ta
concentration redonner tout encore et
c'est terrible peut-être on devrait être
laissé un an je sais pas en fait c'est
peut-être le calendrier mal fait je sais
pas en fait si mais effectivement c'est
un tel parcours du combattant juste pour
aller en finale alors t'as rien gagné en
fait
enfin thierry candidat je viens mais
t'as pas de titre que ouais c'est une
très bonne question que tu poses et
c'est vrai que c'est très très très dur
pour challenger
jean veil montsho quoi il a poitrine at
secondes devant son public pas qu'ils
gagnent ou qu'ils perdent je sais pas
toi news ça dépend des réponses dont
[Musique]
j'imagine que ils sont habillés pareil
en fait que tu as un fixe et un part
importante et surtout s'ils gagnent en
plus tu vas être payée par la suite pour
les autres tourneurs défendu et il était
long et accumule des futurs revenus
les news carlson champions 2010 2013
ah bien tu sais d'où ça vient cette
tradition du champion du monde
intouchable depuis le début un ça
toujours été en fait les puissances en
fait ben existe mais en fait de base de
truc c'était différent c'était pas un
parcours du combattant si tu trouvé un
sponsor
geste est grave à la boxe en fait rien
que du fric le fric et tu dois aller
jouer donc on arrête c'était comme si la
terre ça pourrait en vrai ce serait pas
si idiot qu'en fait le champion du monde
ce soit le numéro 1 ou 2 alé lô pour
exister chaque année que le match se
soit entre le champion du monde et le
joueur ont enlevé les candidats et que
ce soit le joueur numéro de elle et
lokua ça pourrait aussi être une manière
d'éviter ce parcours du combattant
pour break qui est joli hein mais mais
c'est vrai que quand au bout du bout
comme née paulette et être complètement
épuisée
parce que tu as été émoussée
psychologiquement durant toute l'année
avec ses candidats et compagnie
mais tu pourrais prendre juste et numéro
2 3 4 5 alé lô faire des matches en
quatre ou six parties demi finales
finale entre le champion en 2000 ou quoi
un bon on ya plein de schémas possibles
je sais pas on peut importe de toute
façon le problème c'est pas ça c'est la
cadence clairement
si la cadence était plus courte ça reste
face à résoudre aussi ce problème là et
ça te fatigues rémois pas de façon c'est
la cadence le problème de
2 to
sont pas obligés de l'eau 14 au bout des
14 parties cycles qu'un dépasser 7
points donc à ses parents 7.28 ça
s'arrête
la logique ils vont pas faire des
parties pour faire des parties
donc pour l'instant on n'y dont il ya
que des nues jusqu'au bout il aurait 13
parties après dans un sens je suis
volume en lui-même a dû en passer par là
donc en un sens ils méritent ce
privilège
je sais pas c'est une société globale
s'est en fait non mais en fait c'est pas
parce que au début un
déséquilibre on doit le faire perdurer
on va dire qu'une injustice répare pas
une ancienne justice
reste qu'on peut le sénat justice ou pas
je sais pas juste en fait ça peut être
comme ça je suis pas contre ce système
il est comme il est bon quoi pas mais
c'est vrai que quand un changeur faut
dire que c'est pire maintenant j'aurai
ya 40 ans
c'était complètement différent là les
prépas elles ont pris une importance sur
le jeu c'est aussi prendre en compte
l'évolution en
1872 ou 76 quand le format a été fait
comme ça après dans sa qui est pas les
qualifications au moment où il
commençait à voir les candidats en 1940
bon
49,48 en fait ils ont fait un tournant
parce que j'avais qui n'est mort mais
pour dessiner un championnat du monde il
ya 53
53 on peut importe mais au moment où ça
a été fait en fait il n'y avait pas
autant de prépa affaires n'ont donc
c'était moins injuste entre guillemets
et moins un avantage sans était un mais
c'était moins donc ils jouent des quatre
le coût attendu en fait il n'a pas
trouvé mieux mais
tellement logique des quatre c'est le
plus arriéré de la position mais au
centre on social fou
non mais c'est pas une question que
c'était mieux avant c'était le même
format mais en fait moi même c'est que
le monde évolue les prépas évolue tout
évoluer les règles doivent évoluer avec
en fait petit à petit mais bon on va pas
revenir là dessus une centième fois de
toute façon s'il faut changer c'est pas
ça c'est la cadence en fait donc c'est
pas parce que tu passe de 14 à 16
parties que tu change quoi que ce soit
c'est non mais par contre c'est vrai
problème en fait peut-être six mois
s'est passé pour le champ du possible on
fait
ça soit du saint-laurent où je sais pas
enfin
ça pourrait aider
e
une plus simple
il ya eu une fois un match de l'ask est
vraiment une règle horrible quoi que
même s'ils perdaient d'un point il
gardait encore le titre donc là on fait
tout pour être bien sûr et même si tu me
bats 14,2 tu n'es pas encore champion tu
dois gagner 14 1 non mais c'était j'ai
accepté j'ai toujours su que j'allais
faire
[Musique]
après au moment où enfin pendant
longtemps déjà sa partenaire sap a
existé pendant très longtemps ça le
match nul tu gardes le titre à vrai dire
comme pendant 40 ou 50 ans quasiment
fait toute sa
carrière
le titre même stade ces victoires a le
premier de ses six victoires mais je
veux dire faire le buzz unique bronstein
ont fait nul brancher votre unique a
gagné garder le titre my fabrique donc
déjà en 51 cm et steve orenstein c'était
bozzini que je veux dire ouais vous
unique et les magouilles s'était du coup
bon ok vaste et déjà 250 square
magouille et compagnie et du coup à
faire des concessions normaliser le truc
jamais jusqu'à bus jusqu'à 2004 se crame
nick l'écossé 2004 il ya une garde le
titre baisse est de 86 à 2004 au final
cette règle mais avant je suis sûr qu'il
ya 12 12 le champion bien elle qui
trouvait mais ça c'était du fait de
beaux jeans x ou y des genres qui
justifie georges pasqui vu douze jeux
futurs ce parce qu'ils gardaient le
titre
j'ai pas à l'argument sous les yeux mais
j'imagine s'était jamais dire qu'on fait
ça partait d'une mauvaise intention qui
a été gardé dans le temps et après ils
ont refait ce truc là par connerie way
est bon et ça ils ont changé pour passer
en 2006 je pense ça après kramnik l'écho
de critiques et autres projets partagés
on vaccine eu le chemin vers saturne non
mais ça va je peux comprendre sans box
quand eu à départager n'a pas de fin de
séance de tirs au but
[Musique]
sous des pêches sans faute de sa garde
et le break tombe par terre qu
aux échecs juste eu peut refaire des
d'autres partis plus courtes donc c'est
ce qu'ils font maintenant
je pense mais je sais pas jamais lui
l'argument des trucs et comme il ya peu
une ultime ans que jamais intéressés
mais je suis et on pourra retrouver le
règlement du match 72 et on serait quoi
en fait c'est dur de savoir quand ils
ont changé remis skylogic c'était
spécial quand même
ce que vous niez qu'il en a fait les
sales quoi bronstein n'en faites pas
comme l'interprète les choses je pense
que j'étais comme ça jusqu'en 2006
avec me pose avec le nombre de victoires
du nombre de victoires à présent mis une
offre sur swiss ski c'était 24 parties
et à partir de karpov cauchemar ils sont
en nombre de victoires
18 81 et
84 et puis 94 trolonge de la lumière ne
peut plus à quel prix sont repassés à
l'autre pharma
et sont revenus aux matchs en 24 parties
et puis ils ont diminué d'ailleurs
augmenta ils savent pas trop envie en 24
parties c'est moins choquant 12
en fait je pense quelque soit le format
y aura toujours un petit point faible
ici ou là
ok bon ça rentre dans la ligne qu'on a
regardé il ya déjà un moment conseil
nordique est donc présent je dois dire
qu'il faut toujours que répéter ce
qu'ils connaissent n'appartient pas
vraiment commencé en réalité encore
yann a cherché une idée mais je pense
qu'il n'a pas mérité ça c'est sûr c'est
qu'il va avoir
près par chance il peut s'inverser faire
tourner d'abord
j'aime pas si mauvais at war 2005
le coureur qui avait laissé cinq le
maire
et les matchs 19e siècle et rue
labourdonnais
ouais je sais pas trop quel de leur
forme à taëf et les vidéos de ce rapport
il a fait le labourdonnais comme
mcdonald's
une partie fine qui est tres puntos la
d22 est connu voilà
donc cette règle a duré plus de 50 ans
en patois
mais avant du coup c'était en tournoi a
cédé qu'une fois en fait parce que le
champion du monde en titre est mort na
li qin non mais je garde tout avant en
fait le premier pas de champignons de
souk à retorde stein its way to care
tort qu'il était censé être plus fort ah
oui parce qu'il avait gagné le tournoi
tu as thing je pense d'accord on en
angleterre et en fait ce timing c'est
censé être le numéro deux et donc c'est
comme ça que ça va décider des deux
premiers
mais j'ai en fait c'est pas qu'on essaie
de faire ça de faire un tournoi a boy je
prends les deux premiers tu fais une
finale à la farm
normaux ce seraient des candidats c'est
en mai que manu de rejoindre de kémag
devrait jouer
mais ce qui est pas mal c'est que le
championnat du monde à cette époque là
il jouait dans trois villes oui je
faisais un premier truc après foutu
souffler tu changé de ville enfin ces
trucs pas qu'on s'assure de faire des
jours de repos un peu bizarre mais si je
vous raffinée dans une ville fait
trois-quatre jours de pause tout
employeur joaillière mais ça pourrait
être pas mal aussi une croisière mais il
avait fait parfois je pense que c'était
comme ça c'est d'être karpov et kasparov
90 moitié du match à new york continue
match à lyon oui
après je crois que c'était tout même
endroit tout le temps dont
j'ai peu de souvenirs qu'ils déménagent
en cours de route
est ce un pas vrai piège d'un gus sur le
déclin pas trop sur le déclenchement
apparaître déclin pour magnus
il joue très bien la tournée mondiale
est toujours favori à sa propre
succession
bon on se tourne a clairement bella il a
quand même deux victoires d'avancé mais
même prochain champion du monde dans un
an et sera encore favori quoi
ta jusqu'à une surprise je reviens à ce
truc là parce que pour parler de quelque
chose mais j'étais étonné
de voir que sue carter qui était favori
du match
d'après les observateurs mais genre
avant de m'y être intéressé j'étais
convaincu que time it c'était genre à
manger aux sommités du moment n est en
fait pas eu tous les troncs de toi
tu laisses opus music a vu deux fois le
tournoi sans luis aussi et même c'était
bon pour moi cette fin comme ma vision
des échecs c'est pas ce qu'ils disaient
comme je compte pas qualif man ponot
kazim comme des champions du monde je
compte pas c'est luis non plus
mais je compte kasparov krainik un an de
calme c'est
non
ah oui mais il n'y avait pas de
chronique forme qui était le champion
normal en fait
après c'est censé être une réunification
mais je moi je compte ce que je veux on
s'en fout de ce que je pense c'est juste
ma manière de faire des choses ça
mais là qu'ils ont enlevé un topalov
qualif parler tous métaux pas la fille
ont conservé ou pas je sais pas je serai
pas pour moi en fait car c'est le
seizième champions peut être mais je
crois qu'à ce paraphe 13e quoique je
crois que pour eux aussi mes amis 14e si
l'on me grammy 14e à nantes 15e et
carlson 16e c'est juste ma vision
historique les matches ont ils ont
rejoint ce truc là la dernière fois que
j'ai vu un truc là dessus
ils les avaient enlevés en fait après
diderot t'appeler des champions du monde
phil et des championnats classique et
donc moi je compte que les champions du
monde classique ce que
peut-être regarder sur wikipédia ils ont
admis
un an
regardez le menu
tu as puis speed title ouais
en fait tout cela quand il met les split
il s'entraîne on its way dont ils les
ont viré aussi vrai tide les comptes tu
te dis ce film est en fait quand ils
font les articles existe aussi que le
16e le 15e champion de quoi ils citent
sans les comtés en fait ben moi dans ma
faim comme je comprends les soirs de
l'échelle qui doivent payer à toi mais
enfin c'est mon interprétation à moi et
puis
vous pensez que vous voulez c'est votre
meilleur joueur du monde tiens c'est
intéressant ça veut qu'on parle un peu à
gauche à droite donc il vouloir épater
la fin à trois mounir el aarej sa prime
tout meilleurs joueurs du monde tiens 15
159 15 175 rue lopez il honore du
conages connais pas un seul mec beaucoup
trop
en fait besoin j'ai joué plusieurs fois
un tour dans une petite ville etemad
ouais ouais c'est ça c'est en calabre et
c'est un gars qui était de là bas donc
ces cantons paumé et était hyper fort de
chèques meilleur joueur du monde vers
1575 n'a pas ce qu'ils disent et paolo
bol tu connais non il ya eu du bol si si
les boys en fait non
son devoir oui moi je m'appelle paul est
donc belle pour leonardo di coutrot là
il a encore sa statue sur la place du
village pas
magnifique et chaque année pour lui
rendre hommage il faut une partie
d'échecs vivante genre échiquier géant
avec des gens là qui bouge comme des
pièces au mieux ne pas trop ce qu'ils
font ils doivent restituer des parties
qu'il a jouées coin de l'époque après il
ya les cendres aux salves iushko
n'émanant pas par contre
ouais le gall de kermeur je connais
évidemment c'est matt de le gall
philidor isidore sas et xviiie siècles
déjà le gall fils lidar d'échapper à des
chats dre français on connaît aussi
bordeaux n'est pas au newtown adolphe
anderson on connaît tous se prennent
vous êtes tous nul balle molle morphine
à donald andersen williams tami s'est tu
as du carter tu allais tous ceux qui
retournent était au dessus
a été considéré comme étant plus fort
mais là j'avais des champions du monde
non il a fallu attendre le décès de paul
murphy pour pouvoir organiser le premier
match en championnat du monde
c'est ça qui a déclenché le match des
sens reims la possibilité à
1,1360
pas trop s à1 disputed à nouveau oui
c'est ça ça ils ont ils les ont créés
les champions du monde mais tu as ses
membres ce que tous les pays il ya eu
des périodes jorion espagne mon espagnol
as après italie namsa jr donne à la
france après ce parti de partout après
ce passe partout puits de l'ayroule
scrutin enfin les u 13
mai france on n'a encore été fait on a
eu à les quines mais bon
mais comme comme quoi français après
union soviétique états unis on sait pas
pourquoi enfin dominique
s'ingéniant fait mais je n'y a pas de
bonnes raisons y'a pas de raison et
maintenant un bar ou ici en norvège sait
plus quoi
mais je pense que c'est quand même un
marqueur en fait de mieux aider chaque
bizarrement je pense c'est epic a été
c'est un marqueur l'italie serait
toujours à merouana champion du monde
encore aujourd'hui
à l'époque cet arrière car oui
plus maintenant non maintenant c'est
trop mondialisée tu peux être fort
n'importe où sur le quai de raison alors
comme carlson en fait la norvège avait
pas un programme d'entraînement
spécifique aux échelles pour faire
émerger des jeunes issus carlson qui est
stone town du coup j'ai pas de partir en
tête de belles victoires c'est ça serait
une belle série à faire sur la chaîne
gardons bonne partie enfin alors
chronologique de repartir pourrait faire
une belle série de vidéos salon je pense
que vous en pensez c'est intéressant de
voir la plus belle partie de rue lopez
fait elle partie de leonardo di bona en
fait c'est intéressant je sais pas si ça
parlera tout le monde mais ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'histoire du jeu c'est
bien
la femme publique jusqu'à 5,86 comme
richard carlson il vient d'un pays qu'il
n'y a pas de raison que ce soit si fort
mais il l'est parce qu'il a bossé dans
son coin tout seul et puis bon
maintenant c'est même plus tout seul
maintenant je veux dire c'est avec
internet ça a tout changé ça casse et ça
a coupé des frontières mais
bon à trois trucs intéressants c'est pas
du tout le coup qu'on attendait je veux
dire
ah ben c'est sûr c'est pas un coup
débile mais au moins bon
la presse a écrit partie des champions
du 16e siècle
spéciale on vous pique les yeux
apparemment des cas très fort ils
doivent regarder avec ses c'est
impossible
mais quand on va regarder je vais du cc
1 je remette leur dit on va aller voir
ça
je vous ferais des photos ou
illustrations des archives m ça c'est
dur des photos des centaines de photos
de 16 cents c'est très dur une
leçon édition très limitée de france il
ya des nfd
énergique polgar avait sorti une nft de
sa partie contre kasparov je me demande
si je répète c'est de me faire plein de
fric avec mag robe contre carl seine et
oise
villes européennes ft je mets jamais
combien 5000
allait démissionner il a pris brut et
enfin jeu ce que b 4 lors dien bien
présent dans 84 la crème et je trouve sa
décision rapide pour un tel coût d'une
telle importance
et l'agent combien de temps bon après
les ordis qui ont plus de profondeur ils
sont plus de 350 les dix tout ce b
quattro b quattro et quattro équivalent
epr entourent bien
en fait c'est même pas
deux ans ferme en ferme à dos du groupe
bkc largement trouvable en fait rien en
fait c'est une tactique en un coup bas
pour après j'ai plein de trucs
compliqués je passais wallon ça c'est
bon tu sais que tu es mieux la paire de
fou aouita le 24 août à cellules b 6
pour les imbéciles
contre les cadres les français je sais
pas d'où ça j'en sais rien mais bon ça
va être plus que cinq minutes à regarder
cette opposition quoi qu'il en soit des
ses cahiers prend j'imagine que j'ai
quatre attaques très vite intactes ou
abîmées
donc du coup en fait c'est très dur bah
non on va faire réfléchir moi mais en
fait ça va ouais enfin de farine et c5
du commun ouais bah occasion la terre
il a pris en a trois qui
a pas de signe une moto peut être sinon
plus est
voilà
ouais bon faut dire
c'est pas méchant regardez-vous sont pas
censés pas possible il faut qu'on soit 4
tu peux pas prendre comme ça en passant
mais en fait il est fait aucun couleurs
du match pas d qui l'addition comme ça à
prendre de faire ses cadres de fer
bécane de faire de faire dame g7 de
faire chez pac et le coucou à un moment
ça passe à côté et donc si tu fais aucun
coup dur tu veux être à jamais comme ça
il va pas te donner la partie ce à quoi
on peut pas le battre en jouant surtout
de b4 c'était pas le coup le plus dur de
la n1 c'est pas facile je n'aurais pas
trouvé c'est pas là où j'aurais trouvé
peut-être pas mais je vais apprendre
avec ce n'est pas un coup tu peux dire
oui à 100 % je voulais trouver
le
tabac ou pire écoute ça raccourcira le
match et c'est pour lui
je pense vaut mieux qu'ils fassent all
in kita père monsieur nul en fait se
sert pas à grand chose à faire ce qu'ils
aiment
ça lui sert à pas prendre l'eau
ouais mon petit
en fait disons son lots bon bien sûr
normalement pas plusieurs de perdre des
points mais il n'en a pas besoin vie que
le prochain truc important c'est les
candidats il sera déjà qualifiés donc tu
me désole le plus n'est pas
laisser ça parce que roman supporters
dépôt
ou non mais c'est vrai en faites pas je
de base dans ce match je suis pour
personne j'aurais été pour qu'ils
gagnent juste pour qui un changement un
peu et que ça enfin voir un truc frais
car c'est une carte notre candidat qui
cite organise sa cour enfin s'arrêter
sympa mais en soit je préfère panier
pour incarne scène je n'ai pas
personnellement dépôt donc voilà j'ai
pas d'affect dont ce truc
ss oui j'ai un affect met donc
au cou il plus déçu par la ccsa
scaliger l'abandon par avoir décroché sa
non c'est quoi un joueur décroche du
monde
à partir non
non
une fois je crois qu'il ya une partie à
journée c'est peut-être capable ans
kelly qui nous fait
vous fait il abandonne sa revenir
l'envoi de la tri je vous félicite de
gagner machin mais la partie audio kg si
c'est plus un abandon au tour d'arnaud
mais comme il a pu exister en tournoi ça
ok mais c'est tellement des vieux match
karpov et kasparov 84 avant c'était pas
un abandon en
commun accord n'ont même pas d'un commun
accord je pense que j étais très jours 7
et 6 1 car il voulait que ça a continué
à prester peut-être du bluff aussi un
oui il s'est toujours défendu ça après
coup mais
c'est toute la sphère qui écris cette
lettre alors incapable en guerre
je vous félicite pour le titre à tati
tatata
et comme vous n'avez pas gagné avec plus
de six points d'écart je rêve fou quand
même champions vous n'êtes plus fort
mais n'avait pas gagné
furyk à roanne s'étaient pas fier ou un
stick gehrig handicap
et c'était comme en bosnie victoire
facile dit qu'à rouen
puis suit sans forcer même si il y avait
fait un bon match on va être ça qui est
étonnant par étonnant pas qui
s'amourache me wehrli il a mieux joué en
fait dans le match en général mais
bon je ferais quoi vieux damas mais il
te défends des trucs chiants la fin il
ya plus de temps pas fourchette paf paf
tactique tel qu'il est là bas comme
icare ou qu'en fait on n'est même plus
surpris ses matches comme ça c'est
impressionnant
améliorée de même le tour des directs
dus à manger soit b4 soit qu'il prend
incarne cette oppression donc là on
reviendra jumping plus donc ça ressemble
aux rockets barakat sauf qu'on a les
pions pour y est
on a plus b 4 non mais c'est fou c'est
en fait comme b45 où tu l'as dans
l'autre autour des 4 es là tu l'as pas
sur 1,3 et donc du coup nantes après pas
b4 sa nouvelle coupe donc c'était
vraiment pas très dur enfin patrick dur
battu s'accepter et ce contre le temps
et je sais que c'est un coût qui existe
ouais non là c'est vraiment pas bien
quoi
désolé j'aurais bien aimé qu'il fasse
une partie parfaite mais je dois le
souligner quoi je n'ai pas le choix
désolé de le dire quoi
et du coup
qui prend cédé 4,6 une menace ouais
ok quand il récupéra récupéra 3
j'imagine à tous ouais en transe l'autre
ou d'un proche pas
non mais en fait c'est même pas si
horrible ce sage ou
peut-être préfèrerais encore les blancs
ici je veux dire
si j'avais fait à l'éval de l'ordinateur
ou g2 quand même du taf
il a joué magnus non il n'a joué année
poggia oui mais trois
logiques
je préfère les blancs je vois très bien
que mon ordi 2 0 0 mais je suis sûr que
c'est plus la gare et je prends les
plantes à le centre est et alphonse
évite pas développer
au caire on met un peu de pression n'est
pas malgré tout
1 mais clairement
sur les coûts importants en fait il n'a
jamais fait la différence
[Musique]
j'ai pensé que tu t'es un mâle futur à
toutes les balles de break oui tu te dis
va jeter palois mènent en fait été très
loin ce panneau d'un coin
il boit trop de café peut-être oui vous
êtes un autre bon pour la santé on
devrait en vrai de vrai boire du café
par jour non jeu ça
super
seconde en match avancé le match à 7 1
mio des chacals café en fait c'est ça il
faut que j'aille dans l'équipe de dépôt
pour l'ief et rapportera 2 matches 1 les
thermos match à quoi
c'est que ce serait beaucoup plus ça en
fait qu'ils boivent du match a plutôt
que que du fait qu'à
une prime sur cavalli de trois halls et
j'essaie juste qu'un pion à f2 quoi
le ps a fait fourchette quand même un
très grand choc mais c'est dommage
j'aime sur f2 qui te prendrais quoi donc
ouais c'est ça le problème
non mais j'aime qui va re bouffer à 3
peut-être avec la tour
1 et
je suis sûr que magnus très très hot
d'or ce avec les blancs
moi je serais très heureuse moi aussi on
savait tous que les heureux je suis très
heureux avec les noirs aussi vu le
nombre de poubelles que j'ai je suis pas
si mal
bah oui t'as pas l'air bien fait avec
les noirs et quand même
mais en fait vu que tu as joué des coups
bas qui jk tout ça ça ressemble pas des
coups normaux quoi donc je comprends que
je pense toujours que les blancs soient
mieux alors que ce n'est pas le cas
mais on va voir cela maintenant en fait
a priori quand même comme les points
faibles il prend 1,3 et oussalah c'est
vrai ils sont livrés à eux-mêmes donc
donc humainement en tout cas j'aurai une
dire mieux pour les blancs
c'est quand même qu'un chargeur le titre
se plante autant le match obama is a
arrive un jeu complètement se tromper de
cible
la stratégie choisir les bonnes
d'ouverture qui te correspondent qui
puisse gêner l'adversaire etc c'est
important en fait cette stratégie
et et puis il approche psychologique
chacun de la gérer au mieux possible
mais
après je dois dire que carey a qui n'est
qu'à roanne ont quand même eu de la
réussite par rapport à niveau
ouais car nancy par la ronde est le même
match j'ai vraiment complètement foutu
20h05 - 5 écart yakine le nombre de
forteresse qu'il a qui sont pas
forcément c'est pas sûr mort et les
africaines en fait une épaule il s'est
vraiment fait punir oui première occase
pour magnus punition instantanée donc il
est moins de vols que les autres
après ouais
mais après que ronald est raide et aux
autres parties par contre c'est très
bien
c'est à dire que là première ou la suède
il aurait pu et dû perdre mais le reste
est très bien je vais dire qu'un des
primes données peau par rapport à carde
scène que n'avait pas les autres c'est
que ce soit caruana hocquart yakine ces
deux joueurs qui ont des capacités à
jouer à haute intensité pendant
longtemps ils sont très physiques et
seraient tes problèmes donné pour ou de
maxime maxime aussi ça aurait été
vraiment dur pour lui à ce niveau là le
match
la fatigue parce que maxime ça se voit
qu'ils fatigués n'est pas il a le même
problème et c'est vrai que l'anacarde
santa il te ment comme il l'a fait
contre attendant il te mets un défi quoi
physique
en fait il dit que l'option il récupère
quand il ya trois structures présentes
en veux-tu place t tour et tu prépares
des cinq
une petit cheval ans le 5
[Musique]
à voir comment les agences mais je
prévois la bombe vers chaque fois jamais
les blancs voilà
mieux les blancs cette position je suis
tant pis on l'avait 30 noms
maintenant il ya 45 du coup maintenant
40 d'après on retrouve sur nos pattes
ouais
c'est pas moi qui décide en fait les
gens pensent c'est moi qui décide mais
pas du tout en fait c'est vrai qu'il
tape sur les doigts sinon
avant j'ai réussi pendant très longtemps
à lutter et en maître - tout le monde
mais je peux plus tu es quoi
il perd vite mais
bon sa marque de fabrique met un moment
en fait je sais pas c'est bien pataud
rien enfin s'est vu hyper logique tant
sur la colonne ouverte donc je vais pas
critiquer ou pour ce qu'il est mais
est-ce que toro ainsi mieux dames 200 m
dames ces deux mois qu'est ce que j'en
sais en fait mais tu as besoin de temps
même pour voir les nuances dans
l'opposition ça on voudrait je peux pas
voir un pic ouais mais bon enfin dans
me2 c'est quand même le coup le plus
logique parce que tu as un vis-à-vis qui
arrive peut-être céder à ces deux têtes
deux tours 1 c'est [ __ ] au numéro 3 en
termes de la vère les trois sont
jouables mais j'imagine qu'il ya
peut-être une importance à choisir l'un
par rapport à l'autre ou alors peut-être
tout reims est clairement le meilleur tu
sais pas selon le devant ces deux dates
en un coup voir de quoi il prend à 3 est
une décide mais je trouve que c'est
vraiment rapide qu'une prise de décision
alors que ça peut être subtil tout a
plutôt d un tandem un truc aussi je sais
pas fin bon je sais pas si c'est un
mauvais coup bah c'est pas mauvais coup
c'est un coût relativement logique mais
elle de prendre une décision aussi vite
sur un coût qui peut avoir son
importance
quand même
ouais
après les matches il continue de bosser
où ils sont au repos
après les parties ou une fois que le
match 2 14 parties sera fille ans après
les parties donc si tu veux dire après
les parties moi je pense qu'il se repose
quand même mais doivent quand même
préparer la partie d'après quand même le
soir normalement tu bosses pas tu perds
ton repas des temps comme tu peux
peut-être un peu de sport tu as marché
tu dors tu veux pas massage un truc quoi
qui te fait
qu'il soulage
se sentent et je n'étais pas un
[Musique]
trottoir il très heureux des pubs
il ya d'autres requêtes n'ont pas le
temps de cheat des pauses
non on va dire sont fouillés tout est
sécurisé il peut pas naviguer moyen de
communication ou des ordis rien en fait
ça s'est il ya un truc on est sûr c'est
pas possible c'est la cua
vrai plus agréable pour les blancs on va
voir s'il peut en faire quelque chose
mais je pense vouloir aller chercher
dans les nuances pour faire quelque
chose contre un magnus
bonjour tim cook toutes les nuances
je continue à penser que les dépositions
comme les écossais ça lui conviendrait
mieux juste au niveau du style ce peu de
nuances y a pas nuance tu vois là à
chérioux mais
j'ai pas et c'est bien moins bien
aujourd'hui théoriquement pour les
blancs mais c'est
ya pas de nuances clips des coups de
cric ouais je quatre tours
h35 ya des voix
0 nuança
geparo kenny orange et à la main j'ai
une foi qui est parti comme ça est un
fou en a trop on sait pas pourquoi je
gagne
en tout cas
jusqu'à maintenant la seule vraie chance
mais pau c'était la partie ii au noir on
va voir si réussi à s'en créer une
deuxième financeur qui perd aussi la 6
mai
était papa il vous promet quatre jeux
pour lui en tout cas
donc
après cornette écossaise ne donne rien
pour les blancs à haut niveau d'après
tout le monde est la question que je
pose c'est quelle ouverture donne
quelque chose avec les blancs à haut
niveau dudu plutôt dans ce sens là qu'il
faut se poser la question
l'affairé marche haut-anjou un truc ou 7
correspondent 6 à jouer que tombe une
potion nul dette draw bah tu joues à ces
espagnols c'est sûrement meilleur
objectivement
mais il part ils vont faire grand chose
là aussi le c4 manqué avec les blancs
mais j'ai plus de mal à mettre dans leur
haine des avantages parce que fait la
vente a commencé à partir de ces quatre
sites a passé 4 tu n'as jamais vraiment
matérialisé cet avantage où il aurait pu
être mieux mais tu l'as pas été alors
dans les autres partis en fait il se
trouve qu'il était mieux
qu'il faut
faut qu'ils aient des positions et sa
clique tu me diras là elle a une
position plutôt agréable à jouer
mais en fait ce qu'ils puissent joue pas
mal ni possible c'est un petit avantage
il plutôt panne technique
mais tiens sport on est content de voir
les pubs un jeu c'est pour te dire six
minutes de pub sur une heure
par rapport à la plupart des sports que
tu regarde à la télé c'est très peur le
jour même au tennis tu sais ils vont
s'asseoir et de 30 entre tous les deux
je cois bataille à chaque fois une pub
de 30
je pense pas plus que 6 minutes dans une
heure en fait de match de tennis le foot
n'en parlons pas batta la mutante avant
le match entre les hymnes et le truc des
fois maintenant
donc t'as plus en fait
jusque là évidemment la partie vers 8
heures tapas de sport qui vers 8h donc
tu as l'impression que tu vois beaucoup
de pub mais en en densité pas tant que
ça
on est intéressé à peu près dix minutes
par heure en france un zoom sa 6ème jeu
ça en fait ce genre en fait quand tu
vois les séries ils coupent des trucs et
astuces accès là ils te mettent trois
pubs sur des épisodes de 40 ministres
ont motivé le loft ou cause par moi j'ai
vu game of thrones quand j'étais aux
états unis fin de la saison je claque
end avant dernière donc les côtés plus
belle de tous le temps quoi
[Musique]
cette dame 2 qui est 5 alors dit de ne
plus rien pour les blancs
ne prêche pas pourquoi donc en rien son
reste visuellement sympathique
pourquoi ça je comprends pas trop mais
c'est inquiétant
on bienne a même carrément le droit des
temps prix juste pour placer de la
république il ya des temps morts
temps-mort pub
c'est comme ça après c'est vrai que le
sport de haut niveau est devenu
très rémunérés oui je veux dire dans les
années 80-90 un sportif de haut niveau
même au foot ah bah ouais c'était paul m
ils devaient gagner bien mais bien quoi
et il y en a plein d'ailleurs qui ont dû
travailler faire d'autres choses après
leur carrière ils prêts pas
suffire de leurs gains en carrière
annonce a pris comme une proportion
assez incroyable et c'est tant mieux
pour les sportifs 1 c'est pas
mais même là on voit les joueurs qui ont
ils un hello des sponsors partout sur
leur chemise oui oui
on tu vas les vieux match
je sais même pas si un sponsor mais tu
as dit en avait un mais voilà quoi
gagner pas énorme un gars comme
cornouaille je pense pas qu'il ait gagné
2 ouf un nom un mec qui concerne et je
pense un peu c'est fisher stevens
aujourd'hui etc
kasparov mais je suis charité américain
mais bon
karpov aussi s'est mis bien timbrée d'
bon après il a aussi été longtemps à
15h45 peuvent dans rien car je reste
juste un sujet mais il avait pas les
soutiens ou quoi
comme guivarc'h qui vend des piscines
voilà hiver c'est étonnant parce qu'un
et mikati champion du monde seuil a pas
dix mille ans non plus mais ouais
mais je suis patient que je sais pas je
connais pas les salaires de l'époque
quoi mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
gagné tant que ça il a bien du tennis
avis hein c'est pas la question mais je
pense pas qu'ils étaient à un million
cinq par an
millions 38 millions de francs à
l'époque je pense pas qu'il en était à
sa qui marche j'en sais rien durant on
en sait rien en vrai et
tout cas sa cause devant exploser un
[Musique]
avec les droits télé
la pub les contre-allées sponsoring il a
déjoué le carré lisse en dirigea double
encore voilà ouais là je suis sûr
non mais vraiment
enfin si on va on va le voir me l'a pas
dit jade va normalement c'est la règle
quand même mail sur place la pièce tu
dois dire ja double
ça pour moi c'est comme une règle
basique des et chacun leur place il ya
six ans déjà double je crois pas
bon je n'ai jamais fait mais est ce que
c'est je ne sais pas j'ai pas là c'est
intéressant ça
peut-être que vit la personne de façon
de le dire par rapport à l'arbitrage
images histoire excédant les règles du
jeu
mais ça j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait
quelqu'un si un arbitre j'aimerais bien
savoir si le jade ou obligatoire ou pas
c'est une question que je me pose
réellement là pour la peine c'est pas du
troll comment dit j'avoue dans matin sa
fille jade ou peau si l'aja double c'est
international
la règle c'est la volonté de déplacer la
pièce ouais mais comment c'est hyper
interprétable
c'est maxime qui ça
un
autre ami zen qui peuvent y aller
c'est mehdi en fait
attend fait voir
c'est l'intention c'est très difficile
d'avancer un tempo
je regarde fab 'cela va encore une fois
en fait j'aime pas d'être une intention
se peut les éviter ce que tu as un art
qui jugent et tu sais pas ce qu'il va
juger ou pas en quoi
on a tous bien mais il fait
il le fait après c'est comme les trucs
de la touillette oued alors on comprend
mais qui vaut pas le bouger quoi je vois
très bien les images qui veut pas de
bouger
ouais mais alors on avait l'intention
sur le tacle sur mbacké bah oui il est
important que vous le ballon et pas de
[Musique]
trucs d'intention non mais je suis
d'accord qu'on en veut tant que possible
des intentions si on peut
juste du jas double qui permet vraiment
de qui te dit que tu touches pas le
kamanyola je le vois bien la position
qui n'a pas voulu bouger avec l'atout
mais je veux dire par là que c'est quand
même de l'interprétation parce qu'il
s'excuse c'est comme quand tu touches un
jour de procès là dessus lave les mains
mais tu as touché quoi a pas touché ou
à mon avis ça sera un truc à modifier un
truc de janeiro spring qui nous
travaillons il fait exprès is in town
c'est une chaloupe henry jazz the
players have in the mood média just as
we provide the first i express ism
tention ok donc c'est de dire jade ou
encore ryan jones là il n'a pas dit
enfin j'ai pas le son mais je vois pas
cela vous gêne
[Musique]
on va re lire l'article
6 prises oui si fort cela il l'a fait
après en fait
ben c'est normal qu'ils ah c'est sûr que
ça va pas être me parle arbitres mais en
vrai dans la règle règle ils devraient
être obligés de la touche et je pense
conclusion avait pas carton rouge sur
kolo
voilà bien mais dans l'esprit de la
règle il doit pas la bouger mais dans
l'application
de la règle en fait il y fait le geste
après donc il doit toucher il doit jouer
la pièce
bon voilà c'est toujours le même truc
d'être maintenant à un esprit ou dans le
truc mais en fait c'est la règle la
règle à l'éclair salon va tu fait normal
mais tu chef à la non mais la règle non
mais là à l'écrit elle éclaire la rive
mais bon l'arbitré des eaux alors oui
mais sur place et d'une erreur
d'arbitrage c'est pas une erreur de
règles
la règle à l'éclair tu dois a exprimé
l'intention avant de jouer en une touche
il a exprimé l'intention après avoir
touché donc il doit jouer la pièce après
bon c'est sur un tueur les gens à priori
tu fais des débats pourront évidemment
qu'il ya personne qui va le faire mais
c'est parce que personne fait appliquer
la règle la règle n'est jamais appliquée
quoi
tu verras bien en tout cas d'heure c'est
le cas troy qui appliqué
le 4 3 c'est quoi
except as well as in the players have in
the mood for one of those things must be
the first of which can be moved one
maintenant mais ça ça change rien le 4 3
3 c'est pure having the moon the
way i là il a touché délibérément
pour moi c'est comme ça en dehors du
cadre et prévient l'ancien joueur autre
est tout chaud et chic avec l'intention
de dépasser ou de prendre un plusieurs
jeunes doit déplacer à se mettre avec
l'intention oui mes fans l'attention tu
l'enlèves avec le cat 2 de dire ja
double comment tu sais si la lundi mais
je sais bien voilà on espérait il
s'excuse on est assez sûr qu'il veut pas
mais
c'est pas 100%
peut prêter à confusion organique
devrait être simple si tu dis jadot me
tue dix pages à double tu joues ta pièce
tu vois juste au tessin le règlement bah
oui c'est ça là tu peux interpréter
vraiment comme tu veux
non mais j'en demande pas d'aidé mamère
bleus c'est pas un départ inventé c'est
il ya une règle falgère au rugby par
exemple si tu as tu un coup de poing
et qu'après tu fais un petit si je
m'excuse ce n'était pas délibéré je ne
voulais pas
au malheur à beat it mains rouges n'ont
en fait au rugby c'est au niveau où si
tu touches avec l'épaule lors d'un
plaquage ou quoi le visage c'est carton
rouge enfin on va pas chercher à
comprendre en fait pourquoi pourquoi ta
mis ko l'adversaire j'enseigne
à mes intentions c'est comme l'autre qui
avait tout y est son café histoire que
tu avais tu peux l'art raconte elle est
marrante
ouais
moi j'écris quand nbc qui a fait ça
qu'on soit sur scène ou restore mais non
ça c'est une vraie histoire elle été
retrouvée par des parts d'autres
personnes bah je sais pas quand il prend
une tour pour la boue j'ai imaginé une
tour c'est une tour puis chez prada
semble contenir il la prend et touil
dans le café rase et une touillette et
l'art pauvres avec le café des glaces
qui demeure mais je voulais pas je mate
outre j'avais pas l'intention de jouer
j'avais un train de tout y est mon cas
fait quoi et
y applaudir chadoufs avoir quelqu'un à
le dire là y'a personne mais il ya un
arbitre en fait qui doit normalement
au moins qu'ils servent à ça sinon il
est quoi l arbitre à part changer les
chaises de placer le panneau blanc noir
mais du coup la corse a été arbitré
comme voie du doigt nous bouge et à
tours en fait ils n'ont pas arbitrant
mahdaoui pensais que c'était une
touillette non mais ça aurait pris fin
dans l'intention
c'est une vraie histoire et c'est une
vraie histoire
tu vois en fait si la pièce est touchée
volontairement donc là c'était le cas
l'intention de jouer présumés mais il
est possible d'un tank et lundi son
contraire en disant jade ou moins
c'était ça que j'avais comme règle
personnellement c'est ce que dit lupino
là que c'est la règle que je connaissais
mais je sais pas si c'est la bonne celle
que je connaissais donc là l'intention
de la toucher et hélas il n'y avait pas
les jaloux bavans donc tu joues tu joues
et
tu vois ça je vous sers matches
championnat du monde ça peut se jouer à
pas grand-chose à jouer sur une
interprétation des arbitres sur un piège
chez pièce à jouer
non mais et en plus les réelles plus de
truc c'est que s'il vient de faire
bouger le cavalier quand bien même tu
sois pas si mal futur g8 et je sais pas
ça te met en tilt en plus de mal gérer
la suite s'est énervé et peut-être des
autres jours près thénard après la
remise tout le temps et tu dis qu'est ce
qui m'a fait suffit d'âge veux plus
qu'il arbitrait tatata et tu perds ta
concentration et tu commences à penser à
d'autres trucs comme au tennis des fois
quand tu vrie parce qu'ils ont été
annoncés ont une balle qui était bonne
petit du christ qu'un point on s'en
branle mais en fait ça peut te faire
juste sortir complètement de ton match
quoi
a dit sa frénésie s'ajoutent là dessus
quand même ben haim étude très bien vu
des matches de tennis il joue sur un
hawkeye sur un truc suivent la règle
c'est quand même important comme vous a
inventé le truc de nos jours avec
medvedev qui dit pardon
les vrais débats pourquoi cette règle de
merde mais c'est une très bonne règle
puisque sinon on pourrait toucher les
pièges tout le temps ce n'était pas le
cas tu pourrais mettre tes mains sur
toutes les pièces et c'est une règle qui
est excellente moi j'aime beaucoup cette
règle pas toutes encore donné ta pensée
ton corps tu décides de jouer un coup tu
va le jouer c'est pas tu touches tu
essaies ah ouais non ça va pas je vais
là ouais bof
non touchés jouer bas tu touches pas
donc tu veux pas jouer
assez bien comme règle
après faut s'y faire parce quand un
joueur sur internet justement quand tu
sors tu fais comme tu cliques pouvoir ou
telle pièce peuvent aller s'excuser sur
tons foncés un tu vois qu'ils leur âge
si tu me baladant en vrai tu veux pas tu
touches tu cliques t'ont poussé avec ton
doigt c'est fini
tu me vends de jouer
si les arbitres n'a pas vu est ce que
vraiment fait là c'est quand même
incroyable je sais pas combien d'arbitré
mais surtout qui va pas regarder à
regarder comme et normalement je pense
que si l arbitre à côté lui fait jouer
le cavalier en vrai je sais pas ce qu'il
fait il a peur aussi mais aucun n'a qu'à
un excellent exemple c'était candidats
entrent à rogner en langue contre
aronian il touche le roi il dit qu'il la
double il dit qu'il adoube à contrecoup
est donc vous pouvez retrouver la vidéo
sur internet shanaka il touche son roi
il va pour le tu sens qu'il va pour le
boucher est déjà double à contrecoup
après l'avoir touché mal arbitres tafer
joué il a perdu la partie
pourquoi là en fait c'est pas le cas
c'est même situation alors naka tu vois
qu'ils s'étaient trompés quand même tu
vois que l'intention n'était pas mais
ces situations similaires entre
guillemets n'a qu'à me force à jouer là
on ne force pas à jouer
la carcel sont deux contextes avant
différents ouais mais en fait ça tue
mais le contexte non mais ça m'a fait
aller se trouve que tu as raison mais en
fait la règle devrait pas prendre en
compte le contexte elle est assez clair
par elle-même quoi mais cette surface il
met le contexte additionnelles si tu lui
mets moi le mec qui m'était tombé dessus
qui avait mis un coup dans le tibia
imagine l'epo il tombe pour défoncer le
tibia du gars comme ça m'est arrivé en
partie du jury mais un truc pointu au
fond il se défonce moi et je suis tombé
bon bah tu vas quand même pas gagné la
partie s'il appelait cette once d'or ou
d'argent il ya peut-être par intentions
quand tu sais ces intentions ou pas
d'ailleurs l'océan foot aussi des stocks
essayer de défendre comme sa finale de
l'euro 2000 début de match thierry henry
au cours tu perds vite quoi pousse le
ballon on moquait il sait qu'il va pas
venir mais du coup ils tombent pour se
[ __ ] dans ses pieds mais sans tacler
ouais bah oui il ne tacle avec son dos
en fait est là bas je suis tombé bah oui
mais en fait juste c'est clair qu'il a
fait exprès mais là mais je crois qu'il
irait mais à regarder tomber exprès mais
en fait si tu n'as pas ta pas tomber en
fait t'as pas à tomber c'est ça en fait
c'est on s'en fiche non là clairement il
ya vraiment obliger à des parents
surtout que là l'intention n'est pas du
tout dans la règle qu'on a lu en fait
y'a même pas les intentions c'est-à-dire
que si t'as pas déjà d'où tu dois le
faire donc il n'y a pas d'intention
interpréter donc il devait jouer le
cavalier fin pour moi après
des gens peuvent ne pas être d'accord
mais moi j'aurais été arbitre
tu joues mieux la fin permet à 20,8 un
peu
et si tu suis placé un beau diable or là
tu n'as pas la jouer non t'as pas le
droit donc on voit pas de forcer à jouer
un coup illégal
mais qu'en dit moscou 2016 makana
caronha newey là il à l'arbitré a fait
jouer mais à rogner aronian insisté les
arbitres il n'était pas sur les aronian
a vraiment mis la pression mais pour le
coup l'arbitré heureusement l'arbitré
est un arbitre a bien fait après quel
truc c'était pas pour d'autres c'est
normal en fait qu un accueil de bouger
son roi où je peux quelle pièce le roi
qua non mais je veux dire regarde quand
et pau craquer tilt
la partie avant-hier oui c'est un tilt
mental mais c'est un tilt ils la paient
cher puisqu'il a perdu une des pires
partie de l'histoire des championnats du
monde là quelque part c'est un genre de
thil c'est parce que tu as l'impression
que tu fait cette erreur physique de
toucher la pièce c'est aussi sous
pression est là du coup l'erreur de carl
scène sous pression de touche et une
pièce sont adoubés
l est pas tu vois il n'y a pas pu alors
que le fait de jouer b52 nac donné peau
c'est aussi sous pression qui fait la
faute la carlsson il fait une faute qui
est certes différentes mais qui est
aussi une erreur due à la pression et du
coup là elle n'est pas sanctionné parce
que l'arbitrage est par là tu vois
pourquoi le ps alors nationaux et
toucher lecavalier n'est pas sanctionné
géré c'est la même chose tu lui mets pas
la pression il va jamais faire une
erreur comme ça tu as et il ya quand
même un deux poids deux mesures
non mais si le débat
du rena cas qui offrait la nuit la
catastrophe qui touche son cul alors
c'est vrai mais c'était exhibition tout
ça et match de blitz la saint-louis
cheap quand il n'a qu'à ça l'a fait
marrer
il fait bon écoute
c'est par
magnus il a un temps qui veut mettre le
cavalier vers l'avant c'est ce qu'il dit
c'est peut-être vrai mais en fait n'est
pas huit sont défaussés de tilter quand
il perd donc il a tilté il a perdu une
partie si tu as un toc c'est un défaut
psychologique aussi et ça doit aussi
être enfin au pire tu déjà double tuner
vers l'avant
on s'interdit pas de troquer vers
l'avant quand même écoutons ses parents
séparés le débat le débat est plein
chacun se fera son opinion je pense
qu'on a été les deux avocats d'un côté
et de l'autre vous déciderez par vous
mais moi ce que je vois c'est qu'il ya
une pub a envoyé 1
c'était le débat femme c'était le débat
allait bien parlé un petit peu de
quelque chose dans cette partie
mon esprit je l'aurais pas fait jouer le
cavalier mais la règle faudrait la juste
l'écrit très clairement en fait fait pas
50 alinéa tu fais un bon si tu touches
une pièce tu dis janm sinon tu la joues
y a pas d'eau depuis
mes débuts j'ai des idées à 4.4.2
4.4.3 fait 1,4 tout court sans point et
puis c'est tout
une maxime qui avait un truc mais comme
il ya plein de messages c'est
ici on ne se casse la gueule et pas
vraiment libre
c'est peut-être pas aussi haut pour le
coup la hausse et on retrouvera plus fab
même s'il ya pas longtemps ouais mais il
faut qu'il mette un copier coller un
contre la somme de bellechasse mais tant
que cette règle ouais mais on n'y
arrivera pas et des gens qui écrivent ce
qu'ils mettent un copier-coller on
pourra pas
aux blues band nous voir son avis voilà
pour le coup je sais bien qu'il veuille
pas le bouger alors h théâtre phou 17
jouer il développe le fou
plus ou moins logiques 1
j'imagine qu'il est temps que cette
règle n'est pas là non il n'y a pas de
raison de soudainement l'appliquer
en fait tant qu'égérie science et celle
là y'a rien à voir
la jurisprudence qui décide et la
jurisprudence quoi à baky d'histoire ne
comptait pas pendant les neuf pubs paye
wrench
moelle arbitre il viendrait se présenter
et tous cavaliers ça ferait débat y aura
un scandale il varie se passera un peu
quelque chose dans ce match qu enfin
nous on est très très heureux
vers qui a lieu cinq probablement mais
il va faire x 8 non
à saintes en place
non plus tous les espions mais c'est pas
bien grave
un autre débat était plus intéressant
que ça en fait on devrait faire les
chaises vides devance la
maison passer dans la pièce injuste je
sais pas j'aime bien quand on reçoit des
captures d'écran sur twitter
16 bits les saisies de l'allée chézy de
partout
pour vous fait plus de publicité à la
télé
battez pas ça va la chaîne chose comme 1
du coup
sa fille moi je pige pas la position par
l'imposition sahara qui a touché ce
[Rires]
qui est bien pour saab
position
visuellement c'est bien pour les blancs
parce que tu as plus d espace un peu le
centre et c'était après concrètement tu
as du mal à en faire un truc ce que
alors une petite pression que ce soit
sur la colonnade ont atteint le rang de
patron jeu
et
et a du mal à aller plus de l'avant en
fait si tu peux jouer qu'à lieu 5 disons
8 je pense c'est logique et tour à berne
serait que très content en fait
donc tu peux pas et donc comme t'as pas
toujours a dit attaquer même des quatre
avec son fouet vite
bon alors soit c'est tour d un super le
tour un de mes potes à l'heure on en
parlait que c'est peut être un détail
soit tu prends 6 6 mais je pense y prend
du fou et tu reprends il se doublent les
pions ça peut être ça la partie donc
c'est pas ta ble ses pions double m&e
cadenassent bien le centre dont il y
aura deux temps plus en fait quelque
part il est bien bloquée tapas bien sûr
dégager cette dame n'doye 3 et je sais
pas trop qu'est ce qu'on va faire
exactement
b4 et donc c'est
fait on en place avec les blancs
évidemment de pièces bouge pas trop
bouge pas le h4 était bizarre j'ai pas
compris je sais pas pourquoi je 4 tempo
me ferai peut-être qu'il veut faire g4
g5 1 jour
au coq et autres cailloux 5 c'est juste
pas le bon coup ici mais c'est le goût
et envie de faire j'ai l'impression
moi je vois d'autres
je sais pas mais c'est vrai qu'en fait
vous qu'on ne pas grand chose pour les
blancs
ces prix là
[Rires]
pas de chance
en gros pour résumer si lecavalier
je considère tous et les blancs sont
mieux aller jouer s'il reste en
effet si
je suis seul j'ai pris 6 pub fessiers
pas pourquoi en fait
j'aime quand les gens qui sont
s'apprennent des pubs s'est passé et
présent à passer pas il faut écrire at
which criera wrench sait pas qu'il faut
écrire
c'est pas censé en fait on comptait
sable et protégé de ça
nu qui nous dit pas seuls 0 pub on est
très heureux
qui sait peut-être un bug de tri je sais
pas d'où ça vient mais en tout cas
relancée pas le cas - les seules les
chaînes sur lesquelles je suis seul n'en
feront pas depuis ça fait un moment que
je regarde pas si un bug en ce moment
voilà le problème principal des gens
c'est qu'on a du mal à faire plus que ce
qu on al akwaa
hors cac valeo 5 qui est logique on
disait donc pendant la pub pour certains
et que juste le morpho et vite sa contre
attaque des 4 et s'il ya des échanges
massif on sait si ce qu on double les
pions ben c'est pas si grave ils vont
bien s'activer lectorat quatre tours des
à 8 peut-être dame b4 donc faire
pression sur ces 4 / a2 la tour 1 en
fait on aimerait qu'elle participe aux
devenirs en d1 ou je ne sais zoom elle
peut pas de la défense du pur à 2 en
fait très inactive quoi
voilà
quelques conseils aux blancs je ne sais
pas ce que vous faites et que moi
je me pose la même question c'est dur
d'améliorer les radios 5 c'est vraiment
le gicam
gens rentrent et faux buts veut faire
tourner un hors jeu français si ça a
vraiment pas l'air terrible
du coup yard tranché tu fais rien n'y
fait rien on fait rien
le tempo quand même
bon boulot un peu moins
à
pourquoi pas
maxime avec le g4 g5 tkm super heureuse
tu le plant
d'avant septembre est davantage 5 tu
fais un petit g6 tu peux être la
structure
c'est cool ok fois je croise j'aime bien
ça va être une vraie idée simple
un peu peut-être 25.8 tour d un bon
défenseur truqués après le g4 c'est
peut-être une option aussi et c'est ça
le
problème
on perd un pion
ouais ce problème qui ces cinq pas
possible
dans une bonne case mais pas possible
pas possible
ouais
réussir à rechercher sa bouteille d'eau
sans mettre des gouttes à mérignac
nouvelle
le plein
mieux quoi ouais bof ça enlève un
sponsor de la table quoi qui le cogne
bay sont halal files phosagro on à
l'algue ondes
on a plus lokua n'allait pas bien
kaspersky
dodi loisirs chez soi ford prend de la
bouteille
impossible
ce que tu as le droit de prendre ce que
ça déconcentre pas besoin de revenir
comme ça prend une bouteille et de
réveillère une sanction quoi
au moins il se passe un peu des choses
jusqu'au mot d'ordre des scandales comme
ça ça parle vrai match
une bouteille plus fraîches nos sponsors
et de retour discrète sur
l'accès au crédit suisse
il faut vite évidemment
du coût attendu et donc peut-être tour d
un nombre
d un g4 g5 allez je sais pas si la
manoeuvre ces mêmes gens là ne lui livre
pas à ces quatre là du coup parce que
sur gk tueur et cavaliers pros qui a tué
11 se voit ce qu'il veut il défend son
pion
et il se barre
sarrès mieux enfin c'est cool a joué
avec les blancs je comprends un peu
alors dit de ne pas avantage
bas qu'on aime bien cette idée de g4 g5
1 tu as réussi du tennis et 5 qui est
bessette dans le range man dans le renne
cheval
pour taper la partie
fait du magnus bashing
on essaye de parler de quelque chose
de chauffer un peu quoi fin
partie dure six heures il se passe pas
grand chose ils essaient de se faire qui
fait quoi
c'est génial qu'avant-hier on faisait du
néo pop achigans emmaüs bachy enfin fait
quoi que tu dises bon ça ne va pas à
quoi
il yad'autres stream si vous voulez en
fait c'est pas grave bah oui très bonne
idée ça belle idée bravo mon femmes mais
c'est vraiment toi vas y trouve que
c'est pas que ie6 est retransmise pour
les voir on line international
on
sert quand même bien voir les blancs on
va voir après peut-être qu'ils jouent
vite pour déstabiliser magnus aussi qui
sait ça lui a pas trop réussi pour le
moment mais ça peut
voir qu'il ya plus de points en 34
minutes en ami parti voilà
alain bachique
[Musique]
été pas mal beau chanteur
beau chanteur
et quoi comme chanson la nuit je sais
pas quoi
j'ai plus le titre en fait
celle qui me vient en tête comme ça
alain backing alain bacou la nuit je
mens
c'est peut-être sa meilleure je sais pas
je te dis tantôt dormira petites
entreprises c'est pas lui c'est eddy
mitchell nom annonce vient jamais ses
bas qui en fait ma petite soeur ne la
connaît pas la crise à alain s à la
disco afida la vache ou
je connais à 10 entreprises voile est
connu mais tu as je ne trouve pas si
génial mais c'est mon goût personnel
monsieur la nuit
assis osez osez joséphine non mais c'est
une très bonne très bonne chanson
si elle fait je partais
la nuit je mens et aude et joséphine je
pensais de
2,2 mieux
bon allez on dit ordonné vous
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il ya un échiquier gagné
main sympa fait de route allemand n'y
croit plus il n'y a pas eu de roues
alors peut-être une droite bac histoire
je pensais pour le title tête c'est une
victoire
une roue post post partie comme là bas
qui ce soir a enfin faut que ça finisse
assez tôt il reste plus que deux heures
et demie sinon on n'a pas le temps
hemani s'il se retrouve mal autant en
quoi est-ce qu'il peut se faire
grâce à une demi heure vingt coups ça
peut jouer un moment tu prends g4 g5 1 h
1 ça se complique peut-être c'est une
semi bluff mais
en fait tu peux vouloir un truc tout con
comme fouet f3 roi g2g gadjé 5
surface et un plan ça explique le h4 ça
met tout en place et c'est bien
peut-être pas mal joué
yussif vertige de l'amour dont ben ouais
j'aime moins perso en fait c'est bon
goût perso c'est effectivement une
chanson très connue aussi
influent sur le canal touché lui aussi
ses clips ou clips ou fake en fait
clip ou fake j'y crois pas trop je pense
qu'ils accueilleront sur ces trucs-là
acteurs apprennent à cas où ce que le
format veut le faire marrer aussi je
sais qu'ils regardent un peu
j'arrivais qu'un joueur perde autant
championnat du monde
ah ouais
je pense
je pense je sais pas je dirais que
karpov c'est très possible en fait
celle d'or tu vas tu réponds tiède en
tchat
chacun a parlé pendant super longtemps
no fake voiture il n'y a pas que nous
et c'est beau il ya le clip ça va être
magique chypre à coup
un gars qui dit dit que c'est la faute
de dépôt de pourras tu es assis à ce
moment là non mais du coup comme les
armes il doit être là un problème en
fait tu dois tu dois aller vous jouez le
truc même en fait c'est sûr enfin
gatorade accord karpov perdu autant et
beaune unique aussi la philo blida
puisse répondre à pas de chance
car faux film semblait vraiment est beau
et unique du coup je n'avais pas le
hockey
c'est beaucoup en influence
le monde sur les stream on n'influence
paris est pareil influence le monde
ya des fans qui n 9 non non ça devient
quoi ça devient un pur traité kazim moi
je compte il ya pas longtemps en hostie
bonne partie
mais
ouais bon goût du
jour kalichman je crois qu'il fait plus
que de l'entraînement au kazim ça calme
était surtout le second d'inde carbone
avant très longtemps lâche extrait avec
un joueur indien mais c'est qui votre
peau noah bon prono une semi retraité
quoi tu joues un peu par ci par là mais
il joue plus trop je fais pas qu'on
fasse à postuler on va écouter ce que
dit naka hockey vas-y ce que comme ça on
rattrape on a le bon horaire pub où on
allait allez on fait si on récupère et
on a tout de suite de gamme avec la vie
de faire tout de suite
les ali le débat ah c'est très très fort
non mais les gens fait enfin grâce à
nous ça parle non mais pour de vraies
femmes ans on a lancé un vrai débat
l'international aulas et
je vais tourbe est un voyou dame b 4
alors j'ai pas trop compris
oui n'a pas continué son plan il faut
f3c tiré par de quelconques y on prend
et de se faire bouffer là quelque part
un casse à être salis
quelle fausse 3-1
web tv à venir tout en 2d avec g4 g5 qui
nous plaît quoi j quattro est joué tour
b 1
pourquoi pas en face de la dame
ok
alors je sais pas
l'une des lignes possibles
1 mettra peut-être pas de bonnes cases
ça l'idée
après les peuples bronzé gadji
ordi d'
or did
l'avoir magnus doit pas prendre ces 4
enfin quand on ne veut pas
mais bon faut la voir de loin
ça le truc
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec nous
quand on est un petit peu écoutés pour
de vrai et en fait je trouve que les
blancs sont mieux il a beaucoup de mal à
défendre et créneau en russie
ce que ça arrive un peu de partout ça
arrive à être jugé quattro j'estime
qu'au ça arrive sur 17 il est bien un
dépôt quel dommage quand même que de
regrets pour lui de ne pas avoir tenté
le c4 direct c'est la première bonne
position qu'il a avec les blancs ouais
première fois qui suit le conseil de
vlad
mais moi je pensais que juste il devait
pas jouer ou quatre noms mais soit jouée
au calme des trucs chaussoy c4 en fait
mais surtout pas espagnol j'ai fait
quatre parties pour comprendre pas non
mais c'est dommage qu'il ait pas private
comme seconde en vrai
dans l'équipe il a dû tous nous prendre
tu l'as fait du match aller du café pour
moi je pense que j'aurais fait mais
j'imagine pas fait un truc nathan était
la vérité là dessus son cavalier un
genre à taper à la vie
mais je crois que j'ai fait un truc
comme ça une fois j'étais super fou
parce quand j'étais capitaine des filles
à montpellier
sylvain top tous féminins je sais pas
quoi je crois qu'il est une joueuse qui
a vraiment touché un truc
je sais pas je vais chercher l'arbitré
qui l'a touché mais c'est toi tu vas le
bouger ton calais de merde
aurait été très chaud non on l'a vu
moi je suis fier que les arbitres
j'espère un plaquage cathédrale sera
regarde très attention
on peut le faire mais je suis de sainté
mais j'ai vécu à montpellier pendant un
moment et même façon se divisent je vais
pour le club pendant 12 saisons quoi
pendant longtemps on peut livrer
5000 da peut-être le truc
il ya peu le truc
est
identique en échec la police et non
classés plus à gauche je connais la tour
de tours de la babote quoi
j'ai commencé à jouer on peut lire en
2003 tu vois donc c'est un petit moment
bon maintenant j'y suis plus au club
qui ça peut être un jour on sait clubs
où j'ai joué le plus longtemps de ma vie
clairement
à cadix et carrasco n'éveille pas à
l'échiquier pour contester ouais mais
bon un sacré c'est un aveu de
deux faiblesses et d'incompétence de
l'arbitrage parce que c'est aux arbitres
de s'assurer je laissais pas aux joueurs
on prend 1 kg 4
ah oui mais qui y performent fait
bon moi je mais fiat fait h 50
de fait h5 il installe son cavalier un
peu deg 2024 plus rage 3 et il va
repartir h6 f5
hockey et des structures un peu
[Musique]
un peu plus grave
ça pas de belles découvertes
4 c 5 qui touche là maintenant et ce qui
est des gages même pas de prendre ces
quatre
oui
mais oui tu peux prendre
si c'est d'amener ces instants d'euros
je pense
tu as tu dois faire
et du coup il a trouvé une belle défense
russe
mais ok intéressant
il y avait eu un litige en 2009 entre
carlson et firent ucia et la règle avait
été appliqué en faveur de magnus
bon en fait c'est la règle à appliquer l
appliquer tabac on peut pas on peut pas
s'en plaindre mais faut qu'elles le
soient tout le temps qu'elle s'attend
pour quelques seul jour
là ce n'est pas le
meilleur pour l'instant ben
j'ai peut-être val intéressante en tout
cas je pense est la partie la plus
intéressante du match il se passe
beaucoup de choses sportivement il sera
sportif c'est une partie assez cool à
suivre
le nantais 2019
je prends
pas trop
bon d'attac b cette ampleur dans cette
rencontre sans clément son mieux
et peut-être tu l'as pas pour si
longtemps sur le problème comme un
commutateur with me tais toi à 4 du coût
d'accès 4 août
pas défendre soit première rangée en
tout cas
peut-être
que les noirs est complètement égaliser
dans une zone certaines activités
vont de l'activité mais c'est un pion
c'est un pion jsk en objet depuis db7
arrête on menaçait froid
[Musique]
le faire aussi comme ça pour clio iii
oui mon film mais ce qui arrive
au quesnoy la pression avec nous
damien jouer
il faut le comprendre quand acceptions
de plus c'est pas si grave et
joue pas tempo sur damien
iehl a pas
marre il va avoir un truc c'est un des
coups logique dames 1 un des coups
logique mais j'ai rapidement il
réfléchit il reste 19 fit sa main pour
ses scoops agir là au bout d'un moment
il n'est pas dans une phase où ils
assurent non mais il peut vraiment la
gagner n'est pas aujourd'hui
peu ou pas même nom mais bon après la la
la fab
il fait exactement la même connerie que
dans la partie 6 c'est ne pas rester
assis gerder fois il lui est resté 48 81
81 et il a perdu parce qu'il n'est pas
assez de temps à la fin à la faim parce
qu'il a perdu du temps sur des
allers-retours la cie fed à main que tu
fais 20 minutes faits d'armes prendre un
tempo il va redonner en plus c'est un
vase communicant e la minute qui perd il
a des notions réflexion à karlsson et
c'est ça quelque part qui va coûter la
partie précédente
agir tu peux pas répéter les mêmes
erreurs à chaque partie c'est pas
possible
est juste on nous demandait pourquoi pas
d'âme france et 4 bf3
f3 t'attaques le québec a pas de casse
de repli et en général quand c'est comme
ça tu dire il ya un échec et après la
dame va aider mais pas là parce que là
c'était les dames c'est cinq échecs
laura bush baumann qui était vrai nom de
trois ans f 2 ou prendre 5 c'est pas moi
mais tu peux pas
rester pour mettre la pression non mais
là c'est vraiment bas a minima il doit
être dans la salle et panda salle de
repos et faire 4 pas et s'asseoir si la
bonne marche et banny marche mais c'est
ça il peut marcher autour de la table
rester debout d axa chaise mais pas le
plan large on voit combien de temps
humain
caméras publiques
13 14 15 16 secondes battant
ses secondes perdues ces cas là tu as la
dernière fois en fait 34 ans fait du
coup oui
mais je vais magnus
bon faut prendre des satins te sens je
rappelle les ses environs vous fait
il a bien estimé pour l'instant après
faudra encore défendre mais bien joué
franchement c'est pas si simple de
capter que c'est pas si grave ce tournoi
sa seconde sais rien mais les x par deux
par deux faits déjà 32 elle a des infos
il est resté une fois longtemps
multiplié par le nombre de coups ça fait
trois quatre minutes et la dernière fois
c'est peut-être d'une victoire et une
défaite ça s'est joué là dessus ça joue
sur des détails des amis à ce niveau là
c'est des joueurs qui ont un niveau très
proche
le haut niveau ça joue sur du détail à
regarder au tennis ya des matches qui se
jouent sur une balle
5 mm dedans-dehors
tour à
4,2
str ap la nouvelle soit mais c'est pas
de la mauvaise foi faut arrêter dire
c'est de la mauvaise foi regarder la
partie cinq ou six tués soit regardé la
partie 6 revoyait la partie 6
grandes magnus joue quasiment dix coups
avec une minute
si tu es là et que tu vas répond du tac
au tac au lieu d'être baladées le ces
quatre minutes réfléchir sur ton temps
ça change un truc quand même
salle de repos ce qui était plus à
l'aise dans sa réflexion quand je
regarde par sur les comme ça je veux
bien mais quand tu sais que d'emprunt il
va dans les deux trois minutes à venir
parce qu'il va le jouer vite que tu vas
jouer tout reprend tempo et un
enchaînement de coups tempo tu peux
prendre sur soi regarder des films en 3d
quand même feinte et joueur d'échecs au
bout d'un moment
si tu dois mettre une présence physique
tu dois mettre une pression
et enlever du temps de réflexion à
l'adversaire c'est pas une question de
mauvaise foi enfin faut arrêter au bout
d'un moment plein de bon sens assez
juste factuel matin vous pouvez pas dire
autre chose 20 je sais pas comment tu
peux dire c'est
une tête de plus de égale 4 et puis
c'est de la mauvaise foi parce que c'est
ça fait cinq ans qu'on dirait km de bus
de galles +4
le temps
quatre dauphines gestion c'est bien joué
en tout cas
le match dure 6 heures je suis sceptique
sur les 2,3 millions bas d'accord il ya
pas eu d ice note dans la partie 6 ça
c'est peut être pas du tout joué entre
le 35e 40e coup de la partie 6 magnus
c'était très bien autant il lui restait
d'ailleurs une demi-heure pour jouer les
derniers coups et
année je n'ai même pas fait de quoi on
discute des fois je sais pas mais je
veux faire comprendre si tu vas bien que
ça se joue autant tube inséré dans le
jaï t-notes à écouter les conférences de
presse après tu vas bien que ça joue
dans l'agilité donc enfin tatou qui clôt
dit allez joueur qui te disent à la
partie qui te dit al scénario mais non
il faut pas que tu le lises votre nom
mais non ça je suis rien on va continuer
à regarder que des petites ventes
d'ordinateurs et wahaha c'est un pas de
vouloir enlever le côté psychologique du
jeu qui en fait est le important des
rangs en fait
pas con pour défendre ces quatre mais
c'est qu'on se coupe un peu le fourbe et
cette séquence de repli
et peut-être tombe vite bêtement
et ses 5 3 1,5 et je suis un peu con
bon
c'est paradoxal mais peut-être pas assez
bien joué de magnus la camiseta très
bien juger un truc
il a bien jugé le truc après même quand
tu repères un pion on va dire tu perdes
c4 est encore le pion à altorf occasion
je contrôle la casa vite a encore des
petites chances ah c'est pas drôle ça
peut-être juste égal je veux bien croire
mais sans respecter peut-être des
chances
lui interdire à 15 h si ce qu
il aura une belle case
non mais là c'est aujourd'hui c'est une
belle partie pour la pète vraiment
ce b 4e des prêts à 3 kwc j'avais peur
de ces 6 km à 6,6 c'est terminé c'est +
3 est tombé 8v j'ai vu en fait j'allais
dire si fessé 5 s'est perdue instante
- hommage à sa course et je serai bien
jusque là mais la fnja finir il ya cent
ans mais c'est qu'il a déjà fait ça
contre mvm mais en plus je t'ai vu tu es
sûr j'y vis et 5 j'avais pu le dire je
n'ai pas moi j'ai fait cinq six si j'ai
vu tempo il a quasiment fait ça quand
maxime c'est une anglaise mais très
belle femme est très belle partie n'est
pas jouée très bien fait vraiment millet
plutôt bien jusque là
sans lui enlever le mérite mais non mais
oui mais bon enfin favela tu donnes une
pièce tu veux une partie à 18 cents soit
10 700 ont été bien joué c'était moi
c'est un jeu de précision donc ok c'est
5 c'est une erreur que je peux faire en
voyant blitz quand ils m'arrêtent 25
secondes mais là pour la peine j'avais
vu c5 c6 et j'allais te dire tu peux
permettre le pion puisque sur ces six
mois encore du cac et ses 5 pour le
défendre l'intérêt que la fessée 5 tu as
plus j'avais pu le dire c'était pour les
gars du chat à la douce sans quoi non
mais j'ai même du mal à croire que soit
pas une erreur de retransmission
tellement c'est une c mais j'ai vu tempo
vraiment sans ordi rien
maintenant quand ma grasse le film ici
s'il veut quoi il veut peut-être pour
rob et un f3 qui a valu à 6 tours b un
tour à cette attente y aller c'est un
tour b 8 se terminer tout de suite
évoqué enfin ça c'est ok c'est mille
deux cents lots enfin en vrai vous fait
cette erreur ans à battle je vous
défonce non mais vraiment des gars à 17
cents qui font sens ce battage les
défenses
étaient très mécontents donc non mais
oui mais bien géré c'est ce que j'ai
même pas nouveau non mais là en fait
c'est pas grave enfin c'est pas là c'est
très mal joué cinq ans non mais dès que
la juste que je veux dire c'est que vu
le match on en est non mais bien sûr
mais je veux dire par là
mais oui ça fait pas plus et ça c'est
pas personnelle contre eux gagnent ça
arrive de marque ou quoi c'est pas du
tout contre lui si je suis déçu de en
tant que amoureux des échecs en tant que
passionné en fait revenir oui ma chère
c'est une critique persévérer annonce
arrive à tout le monde de faire des
gaffes mais la c5 c'est fou en fait
c'est fou
c'est fou c'est incroyable en fait
je sais pas c'est très étonnant fait de
rater ces systèmes est ici qu est-ce qui
rate en fait
parce qu'ils croient qu'une défense sur
ces 6
et ce qui se dit qu'il fait tordre et
1,8
un but c'est de comprendre ce qui peut
rater je ne sais pas c'est d'abord quand
on sait que c'est moins
34 81 assez heureux de me dépenser au
quai 17 contre maxime je partais
à 6,6
récemment après midi on a des années
et c'est vraiment finale de roland
garros 6 1 6 1 6 1 et un gars qui jette
des balles par terre comme ça au bout
d'un moment il tape même pas dans la
balle non mais c'est benoît paire à
l'atp rome mais c'est en finale de grand
chelem il y peut rien c'est rien contre
lui mais un problème de formation il ya
quelque chose qui va pas on peut pas
voir ça comme spectacle
je suis dégoûtée je suis dégoûtée et
c'est pas par rapport à yann je le
répète je suis juste dégoûté parce que
c'est le match que tu attends tu as
envie de voir et c5 c6 quoi c'est une
partie à 16 cents ces 1600 m de la
partie femmes basse
là ce coup là ouais mais le problème
c'est qu'au échec il vaut mieux jouer
strand coût moyen oui que 3,30 très bon
coup avec une gaffe cette partie tu peux
pas la mettre à 2000 et l'opus tu peux
pas la mettre au dessus de 1000 lots
moi je fais ça je suis dégoûté
mais moins longue j'ai pas le droit de
jouer comme ça c'est ces deux mille lots
1 avec les bons avec les normanus il a
très bien joué très bien compris joue à
2008 mais en face c'est 2000
jardi il l'a la théorie jusque là il
connaît
parce que là il connaît donc pas les
quinze coups qui va allumer par mm oui
il va pas mal joué
il a joué tous coups par lui-même il va
donner il fait pas mes gars très il fait
fausse et 5 non mais franchement c'est
une partie voilà entre 1800 et 2000 sans
fil maxi n'ont même pas de me sens est
parti en
1810 ans et portait un peu compliqué de
comprendre ces cinq ans faute
sans plus juste pour dire il est venu
avec le bon état d'esprit il est si un
truc nouveau fait sa nouvelle coupe de
cheveux et les shows mais en fait non là
je pense qu'ils en salle de repos en
train en train de chialer 1 ce qui
revient pas depuis trois minutes il en
train de chialer en salle de repos la
main je viens de recevoir un sms
les peaux qui m'écrit désolé cave je
comprends ferro que ça arrive qu'à
m désolé
je comprends je comprends
je comprends ça arrive ça arrive surtout
avec 58 à la pendule
il va revenir il va abandonner ce fait
trois points d'écart il n'ose
travaillistes avaient dit qu'ils
allaient finir avec jusqu'à 4
avant le match
j'ai glissé le chef
ben ouais mais ça arrive ça arrive mais
c'est juste le phare est le match est
terminé la bo est resté un 0,1 pour cent
de chances de vous avez dit hier 1% pour
sankharé qui n'avait dit 20% moi j'avais
des 0,1 et tu ailles continuer à écrire
est un thunder qui m'écrit omp tu pourra
rajouter celle là aussi on les pires
partie de façon du monde
à se lasser je suis juste mais du coup
ça accumulent à tout ce qui vient donc
ça accumule aussi sur sa prestation dans
ce match on va dire mais
hélas la partie en soi était pas dégueu
mais ce coup de vernis tout est bien sûr
non après
ouais mais vraiment je le répète une
énième fois ce que j'en pense pas mais
nous on est vraiment déçu en tant
qu'amoureux du vous voyez qu'en fait
nous de base avec fab on est content
quand sont des français qui gagnent
surtout maxime parce qu'on le connaît
c'est plus personnel ou quoi mais de
base on est amoureux des échecs c'est
notre vision de peinture ça fait 30 ans
qu'on fait que ça on est vraiment
amoureux c'est une passion et ses malles
championnat du monde pour nous c'est un
moment de bonheur entre guillemets de
voir de belles parties c'est en fait
c'est ça un énorme immense plaisir pour
nous et du coup là ça fait trois ans
qu'on en a pas eu et c'est vrai que voir
ce match il ya une déception mais c'est
c'est une déception échiquéenne tu vois
comme une balise ce matin là dessus
mais tu vois c'est une déception comme
ça c'est comme pour ceux qui adorent
ouais de autre chose et puis vous
d'attenté avec des champions puis en
fait ça fout des ballons en touche à sa
fin machin et puis que
zéro qu'enfin te dirai bon c'est constat
final bien et puis il ya des autos but
3-4 csc là c'est vraiment arrivé en plus
à ruka la même réaction que kevin mike
ça fait plaisir de voir je suis pas le
sort des réactions comme ça et pas parce
que des fois j'ai l'impression d'être
excessif mais c'est la passion qui parle
c'est la passion c'est vrai
bilou l'année pour nicher en train de
gueuler ben tu reviens tu abandonnes
qui mange le coude mais qui avait
abandonné en fait ce n'est pas grave
mais font rarement donnée puis rentrer
et puisse alors
quel intérêt à voir les dernières
parties ben nous on est obligé un
contrat actuellement mais honnêtement
non cinq parties trois proches juste si
vous aimez bien les après-midi en notre
compagnie et sa wii mais pour l'intérêt
du match si on a plus aucun enfin bon on
voudra pas monté jeudi avant cette
partie
très faible fallait négocier de gagner
aujourd'hui ben il a tenté dans l'état
d'esprit c'était bien on va juste il
voit pas son choix enfermé au patron fut
enfermé quoi
[Musique]
dommage quoi
la caméra clinique sa team aurait dû le
préparer mentalement on m'a choisi l'on
prend fin mais c'est vous ce que c'est
ce que nous on dit depuis depuis depuis
deux semaines on se fait on se fait
défoncer par une partie des gens m'ont
assez ce qui se passe on y trouve qu'on
a raison enfin non il dit on va dire
avant en amont du tournage était ce là
dessus que ça jouerait pour un dépôt et
que
s'il serait arrivé à travailler
là-dessus qui est de ses défauts
il a dû y travaille dessus mais soit pas
seize c'est trop dur de changer aussi
puisqu'il n'a pas 12 ans après des fois
plus on vit pour nos défauts qui restent
ancrées mais c'était très difficile de
toute façon la tâche était était ardue
il a vraiment craqué après il a bien
fait de tout tenter aujourd'hui oui bah
c'est mieux que tu as dit nul n'est pas
jouer après stationnaire que par des
nuls ou que ça va encore perdre demain
et que c'est à dire encore plus vite
en plus en plus sur ces dures dans
toutes ses conférences de presse tout ça
c'est pas un mauvais gars du tout
donc oui pour lui ça fait plaisir qui
finit sur une bonne note
même sans gagner le match juste pour
dire ah bon j'ai pas fait ses efforts
depuis six mois d'un an avant c'est
gagner les candidats il en a fait des
efforts après mon avis pour rebondir de
ça ça va être fort dans la tête de
toiture bon dit pas oui non mais ça se
peut que ce soit fin de carrière en fait
un truc ça fait très très mal afin de
tirer entre guillemets non mais pas fan
je continue à jouer mais tu sors de top
5 mondial peut-être on va dire juste
cette caste et illusions et tes
ambitions et que tu te dis ben en fait
jamais champion du monde j'ai fait tout
ce que j'ai pu je peux pas bon et pas de
vente on est nombreux pas pour être
champion du monde non non moi j'aurais
pu mais j'arrête avant c'est juste pour
poser les mots c'est très bon si j'avais
peur que vois-tu maker moi j'aime
et que je veux dire donc
[Musique]
voilà un mec que tu te dis c'était mon
but ultime c'est déjà vrai pas et tu
commences à juste baissé le pied et
forcément en baissant mon pied tu vas
jouer un peu moins bien peu moins bien
peu moins bien donc tu vas descendre
doucement et voilà c'est sa part fin de
carrière c'est pas juste demandé à brad
de j'imagine pas quand ils ont le chat
qui connaissent bien ma biographie fait
de moi je me suis fait les croisés oui
il pensait vraiment qu'il faut être
champion
bah oui oui et bien évidemment
provoqué ce vélo c'est dur à faire
renaître la partie était quand même pas
mal
jaser de grandiose mais pas mal mais bon
à 5 c 5 sa dépouille partie réglé le
carrier touché par miles
fait foot français ici ça tout est ok ya
six coups tu te falloir rejouer
est au regret pour vous près le problème
là des blancs c'est que les noirs vont
attaquer sous les 7 avec tomber vite
voire même tour hassan darsi les besoins
et le fou il manque des recrues il est
là comment je recule du coup
bah je peux pas en fait et du coup le
chou
à y avait plus
qu est-ce que demain je pense à turbo
d'euros magnus l'enfoncent pas
l'ancien magnus non mes jambes sont le
nouveau menu si les apaiser en peinant
way to kill en bas je sais pas
après
quelque part je sais pas jouer ton
meilleur niveau tout le monde s'associe
de marque de respecte l'adversaire
alors au tennis tu peux [ __ ] 6/0 6/2
6/0 c'est comme ça au fonctionnement le
début tu marques des buts et voilà c'est
tu fais
parti après magnus bas il va peut-être
refaire des dames 1 des machins banner
pot de fer dame sa tessiture ferraille
fuite va être à battre est en fait y'a
de ne pas chercher à te battre à sortir
des nouveautés maintenant il s'en fout
le jeu des titans est tranquille mais si
tu refais rory fuite il va trop bas trop
en fait
si tu fais 40 coups normaux ils te feras
d'une chance ça le truc
me revient il peut il a même plus la
force de revenir là
non ça dure ce faisant cette attente
[ __ ] je suis plus joué en fait ce
qu'ils
veulent c'est pourquoi enfin j'ai même
pas j'ai seulement est ce que je t'ai
pas dit quoi c5 et c6 monsieur on sait
qu'on peut dire ça
or là c'est durant pour le faire je
dirais
et c'est fou donc cette partie si cela
fait dégoupiller quoi
c'est possible
candidat 2022 en velay qui laisse une
place à maxime
après
je truc c'est que je peux rien avancer
parce que autant ce match là ce qui se
passe je m'attendais à ça pour carlos
anna karénine s'appelle tel est le cas
je pense qu'il le défonce à je m'étais
trompé
ya un truc que je m'étais bien trompé
c'était pour les candidats 2014
jamais j'aurais imaginé les gars et moi
non plus j'arrive venait de perdre
bannir et qu'enfin
massacrés par magnus un peu genre ce à
quoi on va dire et donc voilà en plus tu
t'es vachement plus âgé qu'elle n'est
pas et donc je me disais bon lui il ya
de bonnes chances qu'il ait même pas au
courant du dacquois et que bon cela je
vois qu'il y va à lille bon bah il y va
on sait pas il va juste bouger des
pièces touché un petit chèque et puis
c'est tout quoi pourquoi pas non
satisfait chef du jouet quoi et il a
gagné le temps d'un été
et puis le deuxième aux championnats du
monde il a mieux joué après était encore
loin
mais c'est possible mais c'est pour ça
je peux pas faire trop aussi comment il
va réagir
vite et tu réagis bien où tu ou tu fold
non et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui se
connaissent à côté face un jour tu es
bon faut pas trop faim les mots sur un
tapis comprend toujours d'échec c'est la
guerre 60 de l'échiquier sauvegarde des
fichiers et tu peux aller boire un verre
faire un resto aurons tellement la liga
kouame mais pendant le match tu dois
rester impitoyable ce sport quoi
mais ça se peut que ils se parlent en
dehors il fut question fait trois nuls
ne la force pas demain avec les blancs
ce jeu drogba mais va pas fort sans fin
je crois qu'il a même pas besoin de le
dire ça je pense et à 6,7 à site mais
ces années peau de parfaire un rush 8
oui je suis normalement et limpide parce
que demain mais il va peut-être même
urgent ou exactement la même variante
pourquoi pas on a fait trois matches
où tu fais là mais cet échec qui fait
d'un menu du
ska du coup il respirait cinq parties
derrière et la + 3 il reste plus que
deux blancs
mais pour il n'a pas intérêt
mais ça va pensez à wang hao candidature
un truc où tu peux plus jouer en fait
et on garde d'ailleurs il a arrêté sa
carrière à la suite des candidats c'est
pour ça que je dis il ya quand même un
monde où tu as fait quoi
dans la place c'est une raison il ya
quelque chose qui va pas et gigue et
anxieux c'est psychologique l'avouer
mais c'est aussi bien fait que
d'ailleurs il avait tout le temps à
celle de repos pour se cacher du public
mais c'est que ça va ben zhang
en fait on peut tout comprendre ce qui
se passe et tout expliquer ses choix que
ça fait c'est pas une bonne pression
sportive donc on parle que du sportif a
pas que c'est parti bah ça va pas
sans embûche pas qu'on soit triste pour
lui passé deux choses
et oui fait de pas rester toujours ce
bar et danses tous and social
met donc ouais tu sais triste voilà
j'espère pour lui qui pourra se remettre
je sais pas comment il est ainsi c'est
un gars qui vers je sais quand il rate
un temps il rate un tournoi mais après
ça oblige pas de rebondir dans d'autres
donc là c'est pas un thème t'embrasser
le truc c'est un tel investissement ce
sont en énergie en émotions
je te dirai tout ça pour ça
je serais pas préparé du tout aura pas
fait pire
bon jeu
non non vous laisse tomber
j'ai pris une porte dérobée derrière la
vie dans l'appel comment mais peu ko
debout ouais ouais ouais ouais je sais
pas trop ce cas la c1 c'est l'équivalent
d'un ko en fait pour moi qu'il a pris
assez passer par le jeu de dépôt c'est
pas lui
project on n'est pas
non mais c'est vraiment ça c'est un ko
debout en fait là mais pas pour moi
c'est ça
e
non je dois c'est justement ce manoir en
face à l'al fait qu'ils reviennent pas
et tout mais là c'est sûr qu'il est en
train de crier dans son truc de repos un
cd maligne elle reviendra pas quoi
retourne le canap qua non mais ça doit
être terrible à vivre c'est très
difficile c'est mignon tu t'en vois toi
même tu voyais bafin achevons ce but que
veut faire assez bien abandonné
mais se raser complètement la tête pour
apporter ou je sais pas mais là il faut
c'est terrible ce qui vit
c'est vraiment dur émotionnellement là
discriminer en france de gagner les
candidats mais on n'a jamais dit le
contraire en fait j'en ai marre que les
gens parce que tu gagnes une demi finale
de grand chelem que en finale tu joue
très bien en fait ça n'a pas de rapport
la ccc
terrible ce qui lui arrive
là cette erreur là c'est vrai quand on
dit demi d'euros ces gens si longue à
2000 tu te bouffe le bras oscillant
c'est plutôt qu'un 116 100 n'est encore
jamais pas contente pas tu peux le faire
et puis bon il est vrai qu aucun sens il
voit pas mais
après les gars arrivent à tous niveaux
la preuve
les salles à l'evora fin ils ont cumulé
avec la partie d'avant on savait
beaucoup de gaffes en deux parties mais
ils jouent ils jouent à 10 800 2002 puis
deux parties quoi
après c'est vrai que par respect pour
l'adversaire vous demandera quelle
revenir là ça fait un quart d'heure de
n'abandonner que devenir abandonné en
fait juste
mais pour h qui toi espèce n'est pas au
chaos de vous j'ai mis un petit nom
dans leur esprit américain
mel au delà je peux comprendre sur une
fin
de journée qui était pas
mal mais ça je sais je sais mais il est
trop dégoûté
il est juste trop d'ego table tu prends
un million 5 minimum d'un moment tu
assumes jamais la disaient que
je comprends que c'est dur c'est un
poste qui serait prêt à prendre tous le
fric c'est pas existé en votre nom mais
comprend mais jérôme d'un monde tu l'as
pris tu as faim tu dois assumer un
moment donné je rate jamais revenir un
jour mais je sais mais j'ai rien ce côté
là il ya quand même beaucoup de gens qui
regardent des sponsors ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent
c'est mérité mais j'aime vraiment tu
dois venir assumer et emprunte à le
surmonter
je te vois tu dois tu dois faire c'est
mal au c enfin c'est dur ce qui lui
arrive
ces tarifs s'il arrive
c'est
john fisto douleur comme ça
vachement dur et abandonner un stand
pour réparer oui oui
des grands que je sais si ce genre viens
tu dois de tes propres yeux je sais
qu'il faut sors pas
je fais bouffer et a promis de rester
assis encore gunner plus
j'avais même pas là tu te dis je suis
fier a peut-être obligé donc tu te
demandes si est-ce que c'est plus grave
que trois questions debré
c'est dur c'est dur mais on de façon tu
dois y passer un tu dois f18 ces gens là
si là il s'inflige envahissent inflige
un truc un
bijou
il s'inflige
c'est terrible
et magnus qui l attendait l'abandon ou
alors oui il est resté pour
par contre classe de la part de maniche
là dessus il a attendu pour le laisser
abandonner c'était enfin honnêtement
c'est sympa il a compris ce qui se
passait et ouais non ça c'est sympa on
sent qu'ils ont une bonne relation tu
vois de faire ça
c'est assez classe jolis moves de magnus
est-ce que ça fait partie de la
mentalité russe
et en plus
jeune joueur dans la position enfin et
pour vraiment ça va pas absorber tu peux
aussi tour quatre tours à cette étude
iturbe 4 et que sur tourbe évident qui
pourrait filer une qualité aux enfants
qu'on sait si ce que tu as toi prend b3
la fin bachar tu as le même pas un
échappatoire à la pompe comme ça quoi
même avec la qualité de moi je n'aime
pas ça donnait mais t'as même pas cette
option vraiment rien à faire
le regard hagard il est vraiment ko
debout un
mais m mais malheureusement cette
sensation que j'ai déjà pu aborder
chèque
c'est orange ou par inertie c'est
terrible
on a vu à connaître cette émotion fable
malheureusement elle est horrible
mais le mieux à faire c'est vraiment de
riz zain et de choses en fin de partie
de dota de tranquillité fc 2-1 a foutu
revient demain tu te prépares pas
[Musique]
non c'est sûr y'a rien de mieux à faire
c'est dur mais c'est comme ça
web après il a fait ce qu'il a pu
mais il sait qu'il n'a pas bien joué ce
match qu'il a fait ce qu'il a pu
mentalement c'était trop dur voilà
on a envie de casser les chalands alors
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi il
reste là il al'expérience haussier
va être tiraillé au fond de lui même il
s'est lui-même qu'il faut plus rester là
alors c'est triste honnêtement pour lui
mais bon après c'est le sport il ya des
bons moments il ya des mauvais moments
il a dû passer un super moment quand il
s'est qualifié pour la gagner les
candidats
s'est fait de hauts et de bas c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on aime jouer un nom
pour avoir ses émotions qu'elles soient
positives ou négatives un basson peut
éviter sont négatives en décomptant mais
sans l'aventuré pas de positif dans la
vie est un tout fab le yin et le yang
ouais la vie est un tout et
c'est comme ça mais c'est
là ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
dans sa tête
le rogers en 2008 comme nadal à roland
quoi
la catastrophe
même pas essayé à maintenant voilà ici
c'est qu'il fallait juste y arrive pas
abandonner c'est un truc ça l'intérieur
en fait ils n'arrivent pas à le faire
mais
disons qu'avant ils devaient saisir il
reste encore une chance sur mille de
gagner tu as tu peux encore te
raccrocher un tout petit truc là en fait
là en perdant sa là tu sais que c'est
fini définitivement
il revient là la meilleure chose que tu
as à faire c'est abandonner
à les frérots
c'est le moment
mathématiquement c'est pas fini mais bon
y'a quelqu'un sait qu il est
mathématiquement ce n'est pas encore
fini bon là il reste cinq partis ont
gagné 3-1 même cadre du barbouillé trois
mois pour égaliser mais non non mais
c'est même pas mathématique bois c'est
que tu vois la tête des parties la
dynamique des choses la tête des joueurs
bien une épaule juste a battu quoi
ces tristes clowns quoi pour lui quoi
rime surtout ça dure car c'est
tristounet 6 ailleurs cinq minutes mais
bon là tu le vois tu vois en détresse
ça dure vraiment quoi moyenne plus
petits par un palet
15% et karine 20% hilarante désire à
tout encore 10 alors du coup
mais c'est à dire qu'on aura le on
n'aura pas kyo title normalement oui ça
19 reald bientôt 17 heures donc en deux
heures en deux heures devant nous on se
devra aller
nous aussi se remettre en question en
tant que seconde en bas mais mes doigts
avait occulté un peu plus au scrabble à
du sein
nordstrom
l'industrie de
bon en fait ça dépend du score tout ça
il peut gagner le championnat et perdre
des points en fait
mais là ils
[Musique]
ont gagné 10
d'affaires c'est-à-dire gagner 2 avant
la ronde on envoie le truc donc là il va
en gagner quatre de pieusse et la + 6 je
pense qu'après cette partie sur la
considère comme gagné
hier aisée en train de vraiment
s'installer du coup dans le top 5 un
appartement quoique très bon match il
l'aurait été mais mes jeux derrière
l'actuel dépôt et par traîneau
mais pop
neven avons chez 40 ans donc il est
moins
sentir sur son meilleure période de sa
carrière ma mais c'est un peu pareil ça
chasse un peu pareil
un renouvellement et on semble pas
beaucoup de joueurs de la génération
vers perturbé tous hâte à duda j'ai
hélas mais bon c'est pas mal à imaginer
deux champions du monde comme même titre
à la beaujoire
rapporte rapporte pareil je pense pas
qu'ils sont à spa un travailleur de
fouras porte
donc
donc oui ce moment c'est le moment ce
seigneurin ménaka ils l'ont sorti de la
liste alors
27 30 il n'a pas joué bijoux paille
c'est un streamer 1
victoire 4 à 7
dix demandes je trouve heures pourtant
d'une forte à twente tu
sais même pas qui imaginent même par an
c'est trop catastrophique
pas une pièce en fait c'est trop
la somme maximum j'ai récupéré un pion
mais tu vas te faire tout de suite à
deux tubes et f5 harry bosch
on va tomber 8 qui va arriver
c'est pas à vendre
qui part
bouffer le four bon même si il peut
toujours être sauvées donc je pourrais
même attendre un coup pour le faire
il abandonne quant à vendre quand tu
joues de chacun
vous n'aurez pour une tâche
la boj s'est pas forcément à saint lô le
dow
voit son pote qui reviennent l'aider
il peut proposer là il peut partir du
coût 40
mais il le fera pas et ne seraient pas
acceptées par magnus
ce qu'un minimum de temps vous et par
les sponsors un nom il fait si chaud au
coeur même étonnant qu'ils abandonnent
pas déjà
c'est réparé résumer rapidement après on
va être un peu bizarre je sais pas s'ils
ont vraiment s'attarder ouais on va
s'attarder un peu son ouverture machin
mais après
problème en fait c'est
bon dans quel sens on prend la partie si
on l'analyse pour analyser le contenu
chiliens ou si on analyse
émotionnellement ce qui se passe et
qu'en fait il n'y a rien à dire aux
échecs il aurait pu jouer à quatre
premiers coups des quatre où c'était un
trou chien c'est pareil
[Musique]
c'est ok on sait 5
bon
sens pratique
je pense qu'on a un petit peu analysé la
partie oui on va dire non mais la partie
était sympa jusqu'à ce cookie
qui perd sur le champ mais magnus a bien
mené sa barque
sur sa guise de pions défensif en
laissant tomber cette c'était bien bon
vraiment est passé c'est perdre le faut
un temps pour partir faire des coups ici
ou là je sais sincèrement la 14e étape
la casse pour ton cavaliers qu'il occupe
maintenant mais en même temps il ya
papillon de super héros et donc 10 il a
défendu le fond bessette
demain si carlson gagne
il ya ligue et là que si cela
n'est pas saine dans le domaine ont
peut-être après demain par contre
dès demain demain c'est repos peut-être
vendredi peut-être ça va
sûrement samedi en fait une allergie de
championnat ouais
ces normes qui la joue un vrai
bon après écoute il fait des coups
mais là il est plus lucide
il fut aussi du sida
difficile a commenté un
homme droit et pas grand chose à dire
bah en fait je sais pas quoi c'est comme
voir un taureau fasse un matador qu'en
fait tu sais très bien issue
il a déjà trois pics enfoncé jeux
d'écouté pour le taureau quoi
il peut mettre deux coups de corne et
puis un
bep cinq jours a eu droit à fuy 3,7
puis en force et voilà on va donc en
train de voir ça
forcément
il se barre
de partir
vu tout m vers
l'étranger 3 bat ça se trouve ya quatre
ans j'ai 3 juste en fait tu t'en fous de
ces options en fait c'est pas lui le
danger c'est le pion à donc c'est
peut-être mieux d'aller s'en occuper
mais tu pourrais prendre le prendre ce
fait les blancs faut pas faire
promotions offertes à sept tours à huit
non s'ils ont besoin de faire tomber un
tour b vite pour faire mal sauf que la
tour dans l'instant à défendre à cette
fois
je vois tu crains rien donc tu pourrais
avec proche entre angers 3
même si en fait gagner un pion scènes
exotiques dans cette position
yugo demain rejoint un truc fun arrivé
devant tu vas t'amuser tu vas voir les
noirs
et c'est qu'on puisse les faire au
volant
de voitures faisaient à petrov ou je
sais pas quoi
fall est belle par tiens j'avais monde
au final non aujourd'hui c'était bien
pendant deux heures finalement patatras
voilà sur quoi moi je pense turbo
d'euros mais bon après
ouais enfin voilà voir
un jour remettre calme en question c'est
parti mon gars on te dit partie longue
très important on recharge la vérité les
meilleures parties est tout à fait
fascinante
epub vraiment une anti pub là là c'est
vraiment caricatural un
wimereusien
d'hambourg un expliqué le les arguments
gros montants pour les parties longues
ckoi partie longue c'est génial ça joue
vachement bien c'est ce que saidal et
george lemieux
déjà c'est discutable mais admettons
admettons à partir de ce postulat là on
voit que ce match n'a pas trop bien joué
ouais mais ya de la tension est donc
justement c'est le fait qu'ils soient
des parties très longue puisse durer six
heures et une préparation machin qui te
met une tension de ouf donc en fait
enfin si tu dis ça c'est que t'as plus
l'argument des recettes de belles
parties dont il faut savoir ce qu'on dit
parce que c'est des belles parties est
ce que ces attentions rouge et
et voilà mais c'est pas possible de
donner tous les arguments à la fois pour
justifier et
donc on peut s'aider soi des parties non
mais faut pas dire que c'est magnifique
pas vraiment
elles peuvent être longue mais quand
même moins longue et sinon
et sinon ça pourrait être d'autre forme
a simplement
fait tu peux prendre le train j'étais en
train de regarder à cette tour est vite
tour à 6 ou 3 5 pour faire 4 qui est mis
six attaques et 2 qui est des 4e et 5e
ghb tv comme magnus réfléchit c'est
probant qui
[Musique]
partit 19,9 d'après les ordis abbas
était que des prépas
jouais pas un coût mais déjà c'est pas
tout les premières parties ce truc de 4
ce n'est pas forcément vrai les parties
elles plus gros 400 m c'était que ils
ont récité l'aider ce qu'ils ont dû à la
maison
c'est fascinant rapide aussi affaire de
4,5 on va faire une mule en force on va
faire 99
mais c'est juste que c'est trop long vas
tu ne sais pas que faut arrêter les
parties longues je sais pas on peut
quand même les continuer je sais pas
s'arrête mais ça dure huit heures c'est
vraiment
ça pourrait être une heure trente chacun
et 30 secondes ça va partir de 4h
médias
28 tirs ah bah oui c'est vrai quoi
je pense à pire garde tous les
championnats du monde de tous les temps
peut-être pas mais c'est dans leur âge
grâce au rebond des cours c'est vraiment
un mauvais coup
c'est différent de la défaite
d'avant-hier parce que dans le land dans
la globalité la partie était très
mauvaise avec lorie fit le foot ici je
vais vite déjà
h5 je veux pas mettre comme un mauvais
coup mais tu sens que tu as position et
tremblante bombe fit
le tour âge s'ils sortaient sûrement un
autre schéma jouable et puis on b5 voilà
bessane c'est un peu ça en fait donc
c'était donc aujourd'hui c'était mieux
mais bon ce coup c'est un kia dernière
tas de prestations
georges pasqui remplir mais c'est ça
bien pire
or ce truc c'est que fischer il l'avait
g3 fourrage de
la justice et ses 5 îles oui caceis pour
prendre
en ces termes un on va dire que c'est
pire à paris
j'ai pas perdre
il se trouve que
saïd figure à la
92e tu enfin les débats oui on fera on
va le faire mais des vraies photos
censées sur opa ratée en cours de route
[Musique]
grande route romane
ne serait ce qu'à titre informatif puis
la partie avec un des trucs parce que je
pense que je pourrais battre mais bon
alors oui et non le truc c'est qu'on
trouve cela très peu dans cet état là
quoi
c'est aussi parce que carlson lumens
pression et que c'est cet enjeu là et
tout ça mais c'est sûr que si je compte
bien qui me fait défaut prend bessette
des rois fuite des trucs comme ça c'est
pas n'importe qui j'espèrerais gagner
quoi mais juste groupe mois ils feraient
pas en fait
bingo projet 3 a tout bien calculé way
home et magnus par contre il fait son
match là depuis plusieurs jours
faty cueille les cadeaux qu'on lui fait
mais il tremble pas
et
voilà une belle attitude que
ça va abandonner
au tour voix
bakel et a4 en fait tu peux
tu feras vite
à nantes et à sean connery
hockey qui a très bonne question
ces cinq
sets
du coup tu vas 30-18 qui investissent et
et tu sais qu'il fait on fout et à 12
millions de puces accueille cinq
épreuves quatre ans à y apprendre à
faire ça à faire tourner l'été fois ci
ça
peut durer encore
là je crois qu'ils peuvent pas de là il
se dit tiens si je fais le con
fundamento
[Musique]
ses cavaliers f 5 h que ça et j'ai six
cavaliers hausse incroyable
crois que tout tombe tel un château de
cartes
les plus purs ans
5e 35 heures si tu veux mettre le fond
on sait si c'est un tas de dames du
conte garde le fonds vise à mieux de
garder un fou qu'un pion
et donc lyon c'est un acquis et b6 il
sert d'armé bahamas à faire pousser si
steve a laissé faire dame ça qu'ils sont
fous dessus il va raser le roi et son
cavalier
il poussera ses pions
de sting coach puntos
lacalle a gagné en stream constate fiche
bah oui
je pense que je veux alors dit aussi
ac safe
jeudi je pense je suis pas sûr mais le
grand
gagnant avec 3,4 plus régalé
pas trop ce qu'on suit les amis petit
pub maxime a raison c'est la
brèche et heureux reinsdorf
un manque de respect de la part donnée
ponant c'est un tilt après c'est vrai
que normalement ça se voit il s'est
depuis son pion bon ça doit marcher ça
peut marcher
voilà ça se fait plus trop
à ses cadres français
ouais ça devant tout le monde
c'est dur
ouais
c'est un peu ko pour tout le monde
nous y revoilà on sait pas trop quoi
dire en fait
ca souvent
dans les parties 6
après on sait pas si ça allait tourner
en la faveur de dépôt karlsson n'aurait
pas craquer comme ça ah non c'est sûr
j'aurais donné un énorme match il a tout
fait pour revenir donc on perd ya kinder
il est arrivé mais vers tripoli pour
négocier ce qui a tout déclenché la
chute mais déjà
on n'avait pas un bon signe dans les
choix bon ça va faire venir dans le fait
forme larrondo jamais pour gagner ils se
lisent trop de faire nul
mais même là voilà au bout d'un moment
enfin je veux bien au début que machin
et les premiers à défendre mais pourquoi
mais là quand même
là ça dit un peu abusé honnêtement
femmes
même moi qui défend des dépôts des
bulles est ko debout quoi ok ça fait ça
fait 40 45 minutes qu'on est là dessus
ça va tu as perdu tu as perdu celle
enfin
j'assume au bout d'un moment quoi
franchement ça se fait pas trop de
jouets try hard comme ça ce genre de
truc
n'emballe pas s'arrêter là bas mais
juste coutume non mais il ya un moment
donné ça se fait plus
et on n'a pas de vous en quoi on n'a pas
dix ans c'est bon t'as perdu t'as donné
une pièce c'est foutu car arsène il a
été hyper casser les résidences et en
dommages et intérêts c'était 15 nuits
dans ta salle de repos je veux bien dans
mon stop
pression de respect de lui du public de
tout le monde du match championnat du
monde de l'histoire des échecs aussi
agir à cette table de championnat du
monde il ya des cadets des légions des
genres qui ont joué ces matches là et
ces démarches qui sont légendaires je
crois pas qu on faisait ça l'a quand
même il abuse un peu
gérard bout d'un moment j'ai été à la
table d'un championnat du monde d'échecs
moi je n'étais pas dans un café
ça fait pas à 5000 c'est pas dix minutes
j'étais resté seize minutes avant
enfermé dans ta salle de repos à
parvenir
magnus a été très classe elles attendent
eux attendus et tours là il vient de te
jouer le c5 c'est bon il n'y a plus
aucune chance arrête quoi
c'est pas là pour tenter un énième piège
fin c'est bon les pièges tulle et
tentera
où tu joues un piège tempo che pas tu
fais tourner un jeu parce que ça marche
tours à huit tours b 8 aussi votre avis
de voir où est cette enfant 8,3 je dois
tu joues ça et prend sa 5e 5 et tu te
dis oh j'ai peur du second
set des ventes de fine avec deux pions
compte quatre
cafés qui prend soin
mais il a nié toute sa vie d'être
il a sûrement pas envie d'amendé à aucun
moment
vous avez que vous avez quels lots en
fait pour parler non mais en fait au
bout d'un moment
on tourne assez comme ça fait genre là
tu sais que tu as perdu et voilà et
c'est la vie quoi
là ça fait quand même beaucoup géant tu
cliques un peu au hasard dans ses
pensées claires là tu tente de piéger
tu t'arrêtes
c'est comme ça
mais c'est triste et tout ce que tu veux
un mais bon
rifi
a pas de piège fait magnus
feuilleton tour a vite fait ton fossé 6
fais ce que tu veux
victor autant ce qu'il espère
deux minutes pour jouer deux coups quand
il est arrivé
en tête à huit
a montré avant sa tronche pas
c'est ici c'est aux rebelles
est vite tombé huit échecs voit surtout
vous prenez pas vous enlevez vos 3 s il
se fait manger là tout va reprendre avec
le fouet
et
f5
en gros il va les bouffer les pions et
d'un foot+ le pion à sept îles en voie
jamais faire d'armes j'aimerais dire à
force même en donnant la tour contre
l'option ça va être gagnant
4,28 à bien
banny c'est à dire bah on le voit plus
avec ses secrets qu un saint fons de
plus
et rendent fous ils rendent fous ils
rendent fous
bonne offre ouais bah ouais par un
way complexe fab
web à d'ailleurs à un compte est en fait
oui
on verra un signe très fort dans la tête
si réussi à revenir après ce match mais
c'est ça ça sera le côté et on sait pas
la france qu'ils prennent des vacances
se vider la tête
et puis bah soit 60,20 quand je vous
disais ça c'est fini les efforts aux
échecs et va redescendre doucement son
niveau
c'est à petit
soit
[Musique]
je sais pas s'il est temps de se battre
ok c'est une expérience j'ai fait ça
malsam al saman je travaille dessus
c'est de faire mieux
bah les deux ça serait
magnifique d'arriver à faire ça mais
c'est tellement dur je sais pas 2 les
deux très compréhensive quoi
qu'est ce qu'on mange ce soir c'est le
petit couscous un plein de trucs à faire
face se résumer on a mal de choses à
faire en fait là on va attendre on le
fasse immédiatement le
bain après un paquet en plus un truc à
faire entre les doigts
elle est posée fini le pion nra
j'aimerais vite quoi
en fait je pense à des gens qui
qui joue pas vraiment de chèques
et eux ils ont bien dû faire débuter
avec deux dames de moins et quand même
faire des pâtés quand même faire des
trucs donc peu près normale elle en fait
en fait là c'est là c'est un match
complètement de ces différentes je suis
va grandir là ça se fait pas
c'est l'honneur russe non au contraire
je pense aux russes pour y avoir vécu là
c'est d'abandonner au contraire la
l'école soviétique c'est d'abandonner en
fait on te dirai jamais continuer à
jouer en fait l'annoncé pas du tout
l'école russe respecter l'école
soviétique
mais
tu peux pas en fait
pourquoi tu joues mais au contraire tu
voilà de quoi il dit oui c'est une
nouvelle manière des jeunes de fer qui
respectent pas les échecs tu vois
contraire le soviétique là c'est dans
l'indien pourquoi tu jouais là c'est
vraiment pourquoi toujours voilà c'est
l'honneur c'est d'abandonner la
d'ailleurs il le fait maintenant mais
away ici ne pas couler des renvois
mais il a raison d'abandon mais c'est
dur c'est sûr que c'était le tilt 1 mais
est ce au niveau de thil pour pour avoir
abandonné plutôt devait être vraiment
élevé que je pense que deux bases qu'il
avait envie de faire dans sa salle de
repos c'est de revenir abandonné il a
joué par
parce que ça joue quoi
la fin de la négociation du dal et c'est
exactement ça mais je pense qu'il aurait
été lucide il serait revenu lors
abandonné direct
ok bah voilà 6 3 plus que trois nuls à
faire pour meghni sous une victoire et
deux nuls pour pour le titre donc
heureusement
ça sera pas demain ça c'est sûr déjà
même s'ils gagnent de bain et
aujourd'hui samedi ça va finir roland
samedi revenir même le mans samedi
probablement samedi soir ne fera bien
être là comme il faut un merci d'avoir
suivi et on se retrouve tout à l'heure
avec le title et maquis merci à tous
et attention à part du 25 au 30 décembre
sur une amende aux beats et rapide avec
mpl important dijoux maxime
aller chercher le titre mais chercher le
titre bah oui il y aura du beau il y
aura du lourd